[musique]
Olivier de Scuter, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Alors, je
suis Olivier de Scuter et je suis
rapporteur spécial des Nations unies sur
l'extrême pauvreté et les droits humains
depuis 2020 et auparavant, j'ai été
rapporteur spécial sur le droit de
l'alimentation succédant à Jean Zigler
qui est déjà passé sur cette chaîne
qu'on embrasse très fort d'ailleurs. Euh
je vous ai manqué de respect, je n'ai
pas dit Baron Olivier de Scuter.
Vous m'excusez ? Oui, je n'ai j'ai été
proposé au titre de Baron puis j'ai pas
fait le les démarches administratives
m'autorisant à porter ce titre-là.
Mais respect. Alors euh nous vous
recevons ce soir euh pour parler euh
pauvreté, extrême pauvreté, croissance,
euh boussole de croissance et tout un
tas de facteurs qui sont liés à notre
développement thermoindustriel.
[grognement] Déjà, est-ce que vous
pouvez me définir ce que c'est la
l'extrême pauvreté ? Alors, il y a une
définition que donne la Banque Mondiale
et qui est utilisée dans les
statistiques mondiales et qui nous dit
"L'extrême pauvreté, c'est la situation
des personnes qui vivent avec moins de
2,15
dollars par jour et par personne en
parité de pouvoir d'achat dans les
dollars de l'année 2017." C'est un peu
compliqué, mais ça veut dire que c'est
euh les personnes qui ne pourraient pas
payer plus de 2,15 dollars aux
États-Unis en 2017. C'est une mesure
complètement absurde de l'extrême
pauvreté parce que ça veut dire que par
exemple quelqu'un qui vit avec euh 70 €
au Portugal aujourd'hui ne serait pas
dans l'extrême pauvreté parce qu'il
serait au-dessus de ce seuil, juste
au-dessus de ce seuil. Donc ça n'a pas
de sens et c'est une mesure qui a été
développée initialement pour euh
rassurer les pays les plus pauvres de la
planète sur le fait que la pauvreté
était quelque chose qu'il pouvait gérer,
que c'était pas euh quelque chose qui
touchait 90 % de la population, mais
c'est une mesure qui a perdu toute
signification. Et c'est la raison pour
laquelle moi je travaille sur l'extrême
pauvreté mais surtout sur la pauvreté
comme exclusion sociale qui résulte de
l'écart des revenus et des personnes
peuvent avoir de quoi se nourrir, de
quoi se vêtir, de quoi se loger et en
même temps se vivre comme étant très
pauvre, trop pauvre par rapport à
d'autres la société ne pouvant pas
répondre aux attentes sociales et ce
sont ces personnesl avec qui je
travaille.
Alors question rapporteur spécial des
Nations- Unies, ça gagne combien ?
gratuit, ces bénévoles. Comment faites
pour gagner votre vie ?
Oui, oui, ces bénévoles, c'est un mandat
honorifique mais qui me donne un grand
atout, c'est que ce que je fais comme
recommandation oblige le gouvernement à
s'oppositionner. Donc, je présente mes
rapports à l'Assemblée générale des
Nations Unies, au Conseil des droits de
l'homme. Je vais présenter mon prochain
rapport demain même à Genève d'ailleurs.
Et les gouvernements sont obligés de se
positionner. Ils ne doivent pas être
d'accord. Je n'ai pas de pouvoir de
décision, mais ils sont obligés de
réagir et je peux appeler le
gouvernement à réagir face à certaines
situations qui sont portées à ma
connaissance
en utilisant pour cela les médias qui
sont vraiment ma seule arme pour si vous
voulez responsabiliser les les
décideurs, les gouvernements mais aussi
parfois les entreprises.
Et une grève de la fin, ça marche pas
non plus.
Ah, je pense que les grèves de la fin
comme celle que mon ami Pierre
Laroutourou a faite au Parlement
européen peuvent avoir un impact. Je
crois aussi que parfois la désobéissance
civile peut être importante pour changer
la société.
Mon rôle c'est surtout de d'apporter des
chiffres, des faits qui placent les
gouvernements face à leur responsabilité
parce que vous savez, il est très
tentant d'ignorer la question de la
pauvreté notamment parce que les
personnes en pauvreté ont très peu de
pouvoirs politiques, ne peuvent pas se
faire entendre et sont vu dans les
sociétés riches surtout comme des
personnes qui n'ont pas agi de manière
responsable. Euh si les personnes sont
pauvres dans une société riche, très
souvent l'on l'on estime que c'est parce
qu'elles ne vont pas au rendez-vous,
qu'elles n'ont pas suivi les bonnes
formations, qu'elles n'ont pas les
diplômes qu'il faut, qu'elles ne savent
pas se prendre en charge et c'est cela
contre quoi je me bats.
Rapporteur spécial euh pour les droits
humains, c'est les droits de l'homme.
Qu'on soit bien clair, [grognement] je
vais vous lire quelque chose. Devant le
Conseil des droits de l'homme,
la rapporteur spéciale de l'ONU sur
l'indépendance des juges et des avocat a
indiqué que dans cette menace
prioritaire et de décadence démocratique
et d'autocratisation, ce processus a vu
des dirigeants démantelés ou réduire la
capacité des autres branches du
gouvernement
à contrôler leur pouvoir. Un tel
processus va souvent de paire avec la
répression de la société civile, le
rétrécissement de l'espace civique et
les [grognement] persécutions accru des
défenseurs des droits de l'homme, y
compris des avocats, a déclaré
Margarette Satweight,
merci pour la prononciation, rapporteur
spécial de l'Onus sur l'indépendance des
juges et des avocats.
Ça se passe bien les droits humains ?
Oui, elle vient de rendre son rapport.
Nous sommes un ensemble de rapporteurs
spéciaux, rapporteurs spécials.
Combien ? 13 14
on est alors 38 si on inclut les
rapporteurs sur des pays déterminés. Il
y a par exemple un rapporteur spécial
sur le Myanmar, la Birmanie euh qui est
chargé de ce pays-là. En général, ce
sont des des rapporteurs rapporteuses
thématiques. Euh et nous nous partageons
en fait la tâche. Ma mission, c'est
effectivement la pauvreté et les droits
humains. Euh et c'est vrai qu'on assiste
à à un retrécissement de l'espace
civique, euh à une vague de
d'autoritarisme dans beaucoup de pays.
On est dans une situation très
clairement de régression du point de vue
des droits humains et cela a évidemment
des impacts sur la pauvreté parce que
les gouvernements ne prendront au
sérieux la question de la pauvreté que
s'ils sentent des attentes de l'opinion
publique que s'il sentent que les médias
ne leur ne leur pardonneront pas de
demeurer indifférent à la situation des
personnes en pauvreté. Et donc euh c'est
extrêmement important que euh l'état de
droit, la démocratie euh puisse je
dirais euh résister à ce rouleau
compresseur des gouvernements
autoritaires qui est en train de se
déployer aujourd'hui.
Comment vous expliquez ça ? Comment vous
expliquez que dans nos démocraties
occidentales, ça se tend, ça se rédit,
ça veut écouter les journalistes, ça
légifère pour écouter les journalistes,
ça positionne des lois pour écouter les
gens, pour pouvoir avoir une écoute un
peu sur ce qui se passe à gauche, à
droite. Comment vous l'expliquez que
[grognement]
le pouvoir se tende comme ça ? C'est du
fait que la situation générale se tend.
C'est une anticipation. Comment vous
l'expliquez ? Et comment vous expliquez
surtout que ce censé nous défendre ne
s'agit pas plus que ça ?
Je je crois que le problème est qu'on
est sorti de l'axe gauche droite qui a
caractérisé tout le 20e siècle. Cette
opposition là est perçue comme moins
pertinente parce que beaucoup de
gouvernements ne sont plus en mesure
d'opérer les changements importants que
cela requérerait d'avoir une politique
de gauche en raison de la
mondialisation. Ils ont perdu un peu le
contrôle des choses et donc on est
confronté si vous voulez à une
opposition différente aujourd'hui entre
ils ont perdu le contrôle des choses.
Comment dites-vous ?
Pourquoi ils ont ils ont perdu le le
contrôle des choses ? Mais je crois que
la mondialisation des échanges
commerciaux, de l'investissement fait
que les gouvernements en fait ont ont
perdu le contrôle de toute une série
d'évolutions et sont perçus par les
populations comme des courrois de
transmission de la mondialisation
néolibérale. Et face à cela, les
opinions publiques se se rédissent,
contestent le pouvoir qui est vu comme
simplement
humanisant cette cette mondisation
néolibérale et on est confronté à un
choix qui pour beaucoup n'est pas
satisfaisant entre d'un côté cette
mondalisation à peine maîtrisée et de
l'autre le repli sur soi parfois
xénophobe et et protectionniste et et je
crois que dans euh dans mon rôle, il y a
le l'obligation de sortir aussi de ce
clivage et de dire qu'il y a d'autres
manières de gérer la société que de soit
amener à ce repli sur soi, soit amener à
cette cette mondalisation qu'on qu'on
aménage à peine et et en France, c'est
assez typique le face- à face entre
Emmanuel Macron et et Marine Le Pen
auquel on assistait à deux reprises,
c'est au fond à la fois attesté de la
fin du clivage gauche droite et c'est à
la fois montré que c'est cette
alternative là qui est proposée au au au
français les françaises
et les les Nations unies, elles ont eu
quel regard sur la politique française
concernant les gilets jaunes ? Est-ce
que les émeutes ont été réprimés en
France tel une telle une politique
contre-insurrectionnelle digne des pays
du tiers monde ? Comment vous avez jugé
le fait qu'il y a eu des années des gens
ébornésuclés pardon le mot je cherch
? Il y a eu beaucoup de pris de position
il y a eu beaucoup de pris de position
des Nations qui a eu des des grenades de
désencerclement des LBD40 considérés par
nos amis suisses comme des armes de
guerre. Je vous laisse continuer.
Non non, il y a eu beaucoup de prises de
position
des différents mécanismes de droits
humains des Nations Unies pour dénoncer
la répression des mouvements sociaux en
France et notamment lors de ces de ces
manifestations des gilets jaunes des
prises de position nombreuses y compris
au plus haut niveau du haut commissaire
ou de la haute commissaire au droits de
l'homme à l'époque.
et les et et c'est vrai que vu de
l'extérieur, on a quand même
l'impression, ça se voyait avec les
gilets jaunes, ça se voit aujourd'hui
avec la répression des soulèvement de la
terre d'un état qui n'a pas d'autre
réponse à la contestation sociale que
celle de la de la répression violente.
Et c'est extrêmement inquiétant pour la
qualité du débat démocratique, si vous
voulez. Euh moi, je me pose la question
de savoir ce que des jeunes aujourd'hui
qui ont qui ont 20 ans et qui euh
manifestent leur inquiétude euh par
rapport à à ce que l'avenir leur réserve
étant donné euh euh l'état de euh de de
si vous voulez de la planète. Euh quand
on leur offre comme seule réponse des
gaz lacrymogènes, des autopompes et des
et et des et des chiens que l'on que
l'on tient en laisse et qui menace le
manifestant, comment ces gens vont-ils
voter dans dans 10 ans ? vont-ils voter
d'ailleurs ? Et ça m'inquiète beaucoup.
Je crois que vraiment il y a une il y a
une incapacité à nouer un dialogue avec
des personnes qui se sentent pas
représenté dans le dans le système
politique et qui
reçoivent cette cette réponse
autoritaire et très problématique.
Je vais me faire l'avocat du diable pour
commencer. Euh
euh est-ce que les Nations Unies euh bah
en fait c'est c'est genre une petite
voix qu'on entend mais si on pas envie
de l'écouter, on l'écoute pas. Euh sur
la pauvreté dans le monde, les pays
riches sont censés cotiser mettre au pot
pour pouvoir aider ces pays. Là ça en
est où ? Ça paye pas trop, ça paye
toujours pas. les gens est-ce qu'ils
mettent leurs cotisations pour essayer
de sortir les gens de la fin de de
sortir la de de se bourbier ou est-ce
que la pauvreté sert et là je vous pose
la question sert à faire peur aux autres
en disant attention si tu n'obéis pas tu
de vas devenir pauvre donc je peux te
baisser tes salair est-ce que ça sert
aussi d'avoir des pays très pauvres pour
pouvoir produire pour pas cher faire
énormément de marge continuer gément
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
alors il y a il y a deux aspects. Je
crois qu'effectivement
le fait d'avoir un contingent de
personnes qui sont relativement pauvres
conduit à ce que tout le monde se sent
un peu menacé de tomber dans la
pauvreté. Et cette crainte, elle est
largement irrationnelle au sens où si
vous voulez beaucoup plus de gens par
exemple craignent de devenir sans-abri
que la réalité des chiffres suggè
comme comme risque si vous voulez. Donc
on on
plus en plus,
il y en a de plus en plus mais
pays occidentaux.
Oui oui, absolument et les écarts de
revenus vont enfin augmente de manière
dramatique.
Mais la crainte de tomber dans l'extrême
pauvreté est une crainte que les
chiffres ne justifient pas pour la
plupart des gens. Mais cette crainte
existe, elle est elle est elle est
réelle, elle est entretenue parfois. Et
donc c'est vrai que euh c'est une
manière euh enfin que que cela conduit à
affaiblir le pouvoir de négociation des
travailleurs et travailleuses et et et
réprimer la contestation sociale. Je
crois qu'il y a ce il y a cette
réalité-là. Les rapports entre le nord
et le sud, c'est très différent. C'est
vrai que les chaînes mondiales
d'apprisonnement qui se sont développées
depuis 40 ans, depuis le début des
années 1980 surtout sont une manière
pour les entreprises championnes de la
mondialisation de d'organiser les
chaînes de production de manière à à
polluer là où les réglementations
environnementales sont les moins
strictes, à faire travailler des
travailleurs travailleuses là où les
salaires sont les plus faibles,
à
je coupe sur les réglementations
environnementales, il y a des grandes
marques qui prennent des engagements
aussi.
Oui, enfin je je je très souvent ces
engagements sont des engagements qui
sont simplement euh enfin sont sont tous
symboliques pour l'acquisition de
certains labels et cetera. Je je vais
pas détailler là-dessus mais mais je
dirais simplement que chez le mondial de
l'approvisionnement sont surtout
développé
pour que les entreprises puissent
choisir où produire et à quelles
conditions en mettant les États en
concurrence les uns avec les autres. Et
la question des salaires est tout à fait
décisive. On va travailler euh au
Bangladesh, au Myanmar, euh avant en
Chine de moins en moins parce que en
Chine les salaires ont augmenté et
cetera euh parce que c'est là que la
main d'œuvre est la moins chère et y
compris euh lorsque les travailleurs et
travailleuses sont très productifs, il
ils sont payés beaucoup moins parce que
le coût de la vie dans ces pays-là est
beaucoup moins important et c'est en
même temps une manière de [grognement]
renforcer le pouvoir de négociation les
entreprises par rapport aux travailleurs
et travailleus. dans les pays riches,
ces travailleurs et travailleuses
constamment subissent un chantage à
l'emploi, un chantage à la
délocalisation, font des concessions de
plus en plus fortes parce qu'ils savent
que les entreprises pourront le cas
échéant en fait appel à une main d'œuvre
beaucoup moins bien payée ailleurs, là
où les syndicats sont moins bien
organisés voire même réprimés. Et c'est
cela la mondialisation. Et donc, il est
tout à fait important que les
entreprises prennent leur
responsabilité, mais aussi que les États
contrôlent beaucoup mieux les
entreprises pour éviter ce cet abus de
pouvoir économique qui est tout à fait
typique de la manière dont l'échelle
mondial d'approvisionnement se sont
développées.
Vous oubliez les consommateurs.
Les consommateurs ont un pouvoir
honnêtement limité. C'est vrai qu'on on
écoutez on parie toujours sur la
consommation critique et sur le fait que
les consommateurs et consommatrices vont
vont acheter en fonction de ce qu'ils
savent des conditions de travail et et
de des impacts sur l'environnement de
telle ou telle filière de production. La
réalité un c'est que la plupart des gens
et comment le le reprocher font encore
des choix en fonction principalement du
prix. C'est vraiment ce qui détermine
pour l'essentiel les choix de
consommation encore aujourd'hui.
Deuxièmement, l'information dont
disposent les consommateurs et
consommatrices est très faible et très
peu fiable. Il est extrêmement difficile
de savoir exactement euh quelles sont
les implications de de l'acte d'achat
que l'on pose. Et euh euh même si une
entreprise a une bonne réputation, rien
ne nous garantit qu'elle ne fait pas
appel à des fournisseurs, des
sous-traitants qui eux-mêmes
éventuellement en sous-traitant font
travail des enfants, payent des salaires
qui sont des salaires de misère ou
répriment les syndicats. Et donc je je
crois qu'il ne faut pas très honnêtement
il faut pas surestimer le pouvoir du
consommateur et très souvent l'on fait
reposer sur l'acte de consommation sur
le consommateur, la consommatrice
individuelle une responsabilité que les
gouvernements doivent assumer et
arrêtons de nous replier sur eux. Ce ne
sont pas ce n'est pas de là que viendra
la solution. J'ouvre une parenthèse.
Vous êtes belge, on en profite pour
embrasser toute la Belgique parce qu'on
adore les Belges et on a une grande
dette et on expliquera un jour pourquoi.
Je ferme cette parenthèse. Vous parliez
la la répression des mouvements sociaux.
Pourquoi pourquoi on réprimande aussi
fortement des gens qui vont militer pour
les droits de la terre, on va dire
l'environnement ? Pourquoi on sort des
[raclement de gorge] des des gendarmes
super baraqué, super équipés, super armé
? Parce que bon, faut dire aussi, ils se
prennent des cocktails monotes dans la
tête. Pourquoi le pouvoir politique se
tend ? Il se tend parce que il anticipe
quelque chose de très difficile,
c'est-à-dire tous les mouvements sociaux
en opposition ou capitalisme. Il
anticipe quoi pour devenir aussi violent
? Pourquoi il est il est si tendu ?
Écoutez,
vous avez une prospective, une
anticipation, une lecture sur ça ?
Écoutez, je crois d'abord que la
question est à poser surtout au
gouvernement et j'espère que
pose à vous. Pourquoi ?
Oui, mais j'espère que des ministres
vont un jour pouvoir répondre à cette
question euh face à ces caméras. Euh bon
courage,
mais mon interprétation personnelle euh
si vous voulez, c'est que euh c'est une
manière très commode de décrédibiliser
les demandes qui sont faites par ces
mouvements sociaux.
Quand on quand on impose le label
d'coterroriste
sur des manifestants pour le climat ou
qui défendent des zones à défendre, l'on
se dispense d'apporter une réponse sur
le fond. Et ceci euh me paraît
extrêmement problématique. Et puis
l'autre l'autre réflexion que cela que
cela me suggère, c'est que euh nous
sommes dans des sociétés où le recherche
de la croissance économique et de la
maximisation des profits pour les
entreprises qui sont les championnes de
cette croissance
est en réalité la boussole qui oriente
les choix publics, les choix des
gouvernements. Et dans ce contexte là,
des mouvements sociaux qui contestent,
je dirais, cette cet ADN de nos
sociétés, cette boussole qu'elles se
sont donné sont des mouvements sociaux
auxquels on n'arrive pas à répondre
parce que c'est un projet de société
différente que ces mouvements sociaux
amènent. Et on peut on peut facilement
discuter avec des gens qui disent, "Vous
savez, pour créer la croissance
économique, il faut tolérer des déficits
pendant une certaine période et puis les
choses iront mieux euh alors que
d'autres auraient des politiques
d'austérité à proposer." Et ce débat-là,
on peut l'avoir. Mais quand ce sont des
gens qui contestent l'idée même que il
faut que la société privilégie la
création de richesse et la croissance,
ça devient très difficile d'avoir un
dialogue. Et je crois que c'est aussi
cela ce que vous appelez à juste titre
le rissement des pouvoirs
dans les milieux patenté, ils ont une
expression qui est un système
overstretch, hypertendu.
Est-ce que vous pensez que les décideurs
politiques, ceux en charge de gérer nos
nos sociétés thermoindustrielles,
ont peur du trou d'air du changement
d'ADN de nos sociétés ? Quand je dis
changement d'ADN, c'est passer d'un
capitalisme prédateur avec une un
développement en croissance
exponentielle avec une hyperconsommation
des matières premières de l'eau et je
vous en passer les meilleurs. Est-ce que
les politiciens, les directeurs de fonds
d'investissement censé payer la retraite
de certains fonctionnaires américains ?
Est-ce que vous pensez que ce
changement, cette bascule
engendrerait un trou d'air qui pour eux
serait plus néfaste ? que la répression
des des manifestations telles qu'elle
est faite à l'heure actuelle.
Ah, ce qui est clair, c'est que un ce
basculement est devenu nécessaire et que
deux, cela impose des changements que
les décideurs sont très peu prêts à
faire parce que il y a beaucoup de
grands acteurs économiques.
Pourquoi c'est nécessaire ? C'est
nécessaire pour por pour plusieurs
raisons, mais la principale, c'est que
nous ne pouvons pas continuer à
poursuivre cette croissance euh sans
franchir des limites planétaires avec
des conséquences non seulement
irréversibles mais particulièrement
dommageables pour euh les populations et
notamment du sud mais mais aussi chez
nous, on le voit de plus en plus. Et
donc on est dans une dans une sorte de
de spirale infernale dont il faut
absolument sortir et ça suppose des
décisions courageuses qui euh
poursuivent,
je dirais un un choix de société ou qui
font un choix de société différent et et
et propose une forme de prospérité qui
ne repose plus sur la surconsommation
matérielle, sur les gains de
productivité
chaque année plus important, sur la
recherche d'une compétitivité dans une
concurrence mondialisée de plus en plus
forte. Tous des choix qui épuisent les
écosystèmes comme une population. Donc
c'est un changement assez important vers
lequel il nous faut aller. Mais c'est
certain que ça dérange beaucoup et que
les gouvernements ne paraissent pas
prêts à réfléchir
cette radicalité là. Je note d'ailleurs
que même lorsque Ursula Vendreley, la
présidente de la Commission européenne
en juillet 2019 présente son pacte vert,
elle présente ça comme le nouveau modèle
de croissance de l'Union européenne. Et
il y a cette idée que finalement
c'est dans la mesure où cela va être
bénéfique pour les entreprises et pour
leur chiffre d'affaires et pour les
profils des actionnaires que l'on doit
changer de modèle et aller vers un
développement plus durable. Mais on doit
se poser la question de savoir si la
croissance aujourd'hui dans les pays
riches est encore quelque chose de
souhaitable. Nous pensons, nous sommes
nombreux à penser qu'en réalité cette
quête de croissance est devenue
contre-productive, qu'elle avait un sens
jusque dans les années 60 mais que
depuis les années 70, elle est devenue
contre-productive. Elle cette quête de
croissance nous conduit à faire des
choix qui créent en fait de l'exclusion
et qui ne sont pas soutenables.
Je vais me faire l'avocat du diable si
[raclement de gorge] vous m'autorisez.
C'est pas un peu un raisonnement béni
oui. Euh de dire oui bon d'accord dans
un échiquier de guerre économique
internationale, si les pays occidentaux
acceptent de baisser la garde de on
change de modèle de croissance, on
change notre façon de consommer, les
autres pays, ils vont nous manger. C'est
peut-être ce qui explique pourquoi les
les mouvements sociaux en Europe sont
aussi réprimés d'une façon aussi dure.
Est-ce que sans synchronicité du monde
autour de cette question d'un
développement planétaire durable,
responsable, s'il n'y a pas cette
synchronicité,
on va se faire dépesser sur l'hôtel de
de la mondialisation ? Non. Oui.
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
Je je comprenons bien que les
différentes régions du monde, les
différents pays du monde ont des
trajectoires de développement
différents. Et dans les pays riches, la
croissance qui a permis de répondre à
toute une série de besoins essentiels
jusque dans les années 50 60 euh écoles,
hôpitaux,
infrastructure de transport en commun et
cetera, c'était très important.
Aujourd'hui, on est dans une époque euh
ou dans une phase de développement où la
croissance n'est plus euh souhaitable.
Elle crée plus d'effets pervers qu'elle
amène davantage dans les pays riches.
Mais dans beaucoup de pays pauvres, il
faut encore de la croissance euh parce
que les besoins essentiels de population
doivent encore euh être satisfaits parce
qu'il faut investir dans des dans des
infrastructures. Il ne suffit pas de
maintenir l'économie dans son
fonctionnement tel qu'il est. Il faut
améliorer son fonctionnement et
investir. Il faut là de la croissance.
Combien ? Et le vrai problème, je je
termine juste, le vrai problème, c'est
que ces développements doivent être
dissociés l'un de l'autre. c'est que si
les pays pauvres qui doivent encore
développer en croissant reposent sur les
exportations vers les pays riches, il
faut de la croissance dans les pays
riches pour absorber ces exportations.
Et donc le problème est celui de cette
interdépendance aujourd'hui qui est très
difficile à gérer. Donc ce qu'il faut
c'est que nous arrêtions de croître dans
les pays riches, que nous acceptions que
les pays pauvres, les pays en
développement continue de croître pour
le bien-être de leur population et que
les relations commerciales
internationales gèrent cette
désynchronisation. C'est-à-dire que en
même temps qu'on va vers une économie
stationnaire chez nous, on tolère un
développement continu dans les pays qui
ont besoin de se développer. Et ceci
peut se faire par exemple par, et c'est
ce que fait l'Union européenne, par des
conditions imposées à l'accès aux
marchandises euh dans le marché de
l'Union européenne par euh euh des
conditions liées au développement des
chaînes d'approvisionnement pour que les
droits des travailleurs et travailleuses
soient respectés, pour que les règles
environnementales soient respectées et
cetera. Bref, pour protéger l'Union
européenne d'une concurrence déloyale
qui viendrait de ce que dans d'autres
pays, on ne respecte pas, on ne
respecterait pas les règles du jeu qui
sont des règles multilatérales, si vous
voulez. Donc je crois que il est
possible d'organiser la décroissance ou
d'organiser l'économie stationnaire ou
la post-croissance, mais ça suppose que
l'on adapte les politiques extérieures,
les politiques commerciales notamment
euh à cette transition qu'on doit faire
à l'intérieur.
Ça a pas l'air du tout de prendre le ce
chemin-là. Il y a toujours une guerre
économique gravissime entre état entre
état sous-développé et État développé
entre État développé. Comment vous
percevez le concept [raclement de gorge]
la réalité [grognement] de la guerre
économique ? la guerre économique en
sous main à écouter les autres attraper
les marchés des autres se on a vu ça
pendant le covid avec les masques où les
gens à la limite se battaient sur les
tarmacs où les douaniers bloquaient les
exportations de masque à gauche à
droite.
On n'est pas devenu tellement égoïste
à un point d'égoïsme dingue que si on
part sur une économie comme vous
l'appeler stationnaire,
ça risque aussi de créer chez nous des
troubles.
Écoutez, je je crois qu'on va vers un
monde où
le risque de conflit va augmenter avec
l'accaparement des ressources et la
concurrence entre États. Absolument.
Mais cette issue n'est pas inévitable.
Je relève d'ailleurs que dans les
politiques qui sont mises sur pied
aujourd'hui dans l'Union européenne, on
a combiné et je m'en félicite, je m'en
réjouis, on a combiné la tentative de
faire une transition écologique à
l'intérieur des frontières de l'Union
européenne avec des mesures prises dans
nos rapports à l'étranger. Je prends
deux exemples. D'abord,
la taxe carbone aux frontières. la taxe
carbone aux frontières qui permet de
protéger les entreprises européennes du
risque d'une concurrence déloyale de
d'entreprise
exportant vers l'Union européenne sans
être soumise aux mêmes contraintes
environnementales là où elles
produisent. C'est très important et ça
permet de aux entreprises européennes de
de de faire leur propre transition sans
sur cette sans subir cette concurrence
et on fait d'une certaine manière la
même chose pour les droits sociaux avec
l'imposition de mesures et la France a
été un peu leader dans ce domaine
l'imposition de mesures aux entreprises
obligeant les entreprises à surveiller
la chaîne d'approvisionnement pour
s'assurer que les droits humains et les
droits des travailleurs et travailleuses
soient respectés par leurs fournisseurs,
leurs sous-traitants dans toute la
chaîne. d'approvisionnement, manière de
se protéger contre ce qu'on appelle le
dumping social, c'est-à-dire une
concurrence déloyale reposant sur la
violation des règles qui régissent les
droits des droits au travail. Et donc
c'est important, ça montre que au fond
la mondisation
qu'on avait un peu sacralisé il y a 30
ou 40 ans est maintenant une mondisation
qu'on essaie de domestiquer. Alors c'est
difficile à faire. Les États ont été
très lents à se mettre en route, mais si
on le fait en faisant référence à des
normes internationales plutôt qu'en
imposant à l'Inde, aux Philippines ou à
l'Afrique du Sud euh les normes qui sont
en vigueur chez nous, si on le fait en
référence avec des à des objectifs
multilatéraux comme les objectifs de
développement durable, l'on peut aller
vers une modernisation bien plus
maîtrisée et qui nous permet de sortir
de cette ce protectionnisme empreint de
xénophobie auquel on nous on on enfin
qu'on nous propose parfois ou bien cette
mondisation néolibérale qui a causé
tellement de dégâts depuis 40 ans.
Ça a été chiffré le la le taux de
croissance nécessaire pour les pays
entre guillemets sous-développés.
Il proposent combien ? On leur propose
combien ? Ils veulent combien ? Est-ce
qu'ils veulent avoir le même niveau de
vie qu'on a à l'heure actuelle ?
Qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent ? Non. Alors
vous avez chiffré ça à combien de
trilliards de dollars ? Écoutez, ces
pays recherchent la croissance parce
qu'il ils veulent créer de la richesse
pour investir. On peut l'espérer, au
bénéfice de leur population. Le vrai
problème, c'est que très souvent cette
croissance, elle est un euh stimulée par
les exportations vers les pays riches.
Et donc quand les pays riches sont en
crise, ces pays-là ont subissent ses
impacts. Et c'est c'est c'est ce qu'on
évoquait il y a une minute et ça me
paraît extrêmement problématique comme
modèle de développement. Et et
deuxièmement, la croissance parfois ne
bénéficie pas aux personnes en pauvreté
dans ces pays. Et un des objectifs de
développement durable adoptés en 2015,
c'est que la croissance bénéficie
d'abord aux 40 % les plus pauvres dans
ces pays, c'est-à-dire qu'elle soit
inclusive, mais aujourd'hui, elle est
très souvent excluante, c'est-à-dire que
la croissance bénéficie aux élites
économiques qui contrôlent le secteur de
l'import export et et et et et contrôle
les chaînes mondiales de
l'approvisionnement, mais ne bénéficie
pas aux personnes en pauvreté. Et je
dirais même que parfois l'on justifie
que l'on n'augmente pas les salaires
dans ces pays, que l'on continue de de
réprimer les syndicats euh et de refuser
la négociation collective au nom de la
compétitivité dans les chaînes mondiales
d'approvisionnement, dans cette
concurrence mondialisée que l'on doit
maintenir. Et je connais des pays où
l'on répond aux syndicats qui veulent
des augmentations de salaires.
Quel pays ?
Mais par exemple au Malais, au
Bangladesh et cetera. La réponse typique
que l'on donne aux travailleurs et
travailleuses qui veulent voir augmenter
les salaires comme manière de réduire la
pauvreté dans le pays, c'est si on
augmente les salaires, on va perdre des
parts de marché et les les acheteurs,
les grandes firmes internationales, les
grandes sociétés transnationales
généralement domicilié en Europe ou aux
États-Unis ne vont plus venir chez nous
et iront vers des pays qui ont des
salaires plus bas. Et donc c'est très
problématique ça. C'est une manière de
décourager le progrès social la même ou
la pauvreté est la plus est la plus
grande.
Et et mais si on alors nous en Europe et
surtout en France, on a entendu dire que
si on augmentait les salaires, ça allait
augmenter l'inflation. Qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez ?
Alors, il y a des études là-dessus qui
montrent que ce n'est pas vrai, que
c'est
c'est pour ça que l'Union européenne,
ils sont augmentés de 13 % et queils ont
déconseillé de le faire pour le reste
des des des salariés. C'est ça.
Écoutez, j'ignore cette information. Je
peux vous dire que dans des pays comme
la Belgique, Chypre de Luxembourg, on a
une indexation automatique des salaires
au coût de la vie. Au Luxembourg, on
exclut le tabac, l'alcool et le pétrole
de ce calcul. Mais en gros, les salaires
augmentent automatiquement à mesure que
le coût de la vie augmente et on n pas
de spirale inflationniste. Et le FMI
d'ailleurs a fait une étude en octobre
2022 euh parcourant tout un ensemble
d'épisodes depuis 50 ans dans les pays
riches euh de de de d'augmentation des
salaires liés à à l'inflation en
montrant que cela ne stimulait pas une
une continuité de de l'inflation. Donc
c'est un mythe que l'augmentation des
salaires nourrirait l'inflation et c'est
un un prétexte pour ne pas au fond
préserver le pouvoir d'achat des
populations les plus vulnérables. les
droits de l'homme, la démocratie, est-ce
que c'est pas un peu un épiphénomène
basé sur une consommation énergétique
exponentielle et que si on rentre en
décruation énergétique,
bah les droits de l'homme, les droits
humains, la démocratie va se réduire
comme pot de chagrin.
Écoutez, c'est une crainte qu'on exprime
parfois, mais
je considère pour ma part qu'on peut
satisfaire des besoins importants,
essentiel en matière de logement,
d'alimentation, de santé
par d'autres moyens que par
l'augmentation de la consommation
privée. On peut [grognement] le faire en
développement des les biens publics, les
services publics. Je prends un exemple,
le droit à la mobilité est absolument
important, mais ça ne veut pas dire
nécessairement que tous les ménages
doivent avoir accès à la voiture
individuelle si on développe des réseaux
de transport en commun performant
permettant de limiter la pollution liée
à la voiture individuelle, permettant
l'accès à la mobilité pour tous et
toutes, même pour les ménages en
situation précaire qui ne peuvent pas se
permettre une voiture individuelle. Et
de la même manière euh on peut euh
garantir le droit au logement euh sans
que ça doive se traduire par l'accès à
des à des à des à des pavillons pour
pour tout le monde. Il il faut investir
davantage dans des logements sociaux à
proximité des des lieux où se trouvent
les emplois, les lieux de culture et
l'école. Et donc je crois que il faut
certainement répondre aux attentes des
populations qui ont des attentes
légitimes de satisfaire ces besoins-là,
mais ça ne doit pas nécessairement
passer par l'augmentation de la
consommation privée.
Dans votre modèle,
la démographie, elle est prise en
compte. Qu'est-ce qu'on va dire ? On va
dire aux pays occidentaux, bon, on est
dans une économie, comment vous dites ?
Une économie
stationnaire. Donc, il faut que notre
démographie soit stationnaire. Est-ce
que on va dire au Nigéria, bon écoutez
les gars, on rentre en économie
stationnaire où vous allez être aussi un
petit peu en croissance.
Est-ce qu'on en parle ? Est-ce qu'on en
parle pas ? Est-ce que c'est une théorie
qui ne vaut pas la coup le coup d'en
parler ? Écoutez, c'est un c'est un
enjeu majeur qui est largement un tabou
euh notamment au sein des Nations Unies,
notamment parce que si vous voulez
l'augmentation de la population et la
population double dans certains pays
tous les 25 ou 30 ans. Donc ça, il y a
des pays d'Afrique notamment où la la
croissance démographique demeure
extrêmement forte. Et et pourquoi est-ce
qu'on en parle pas ? Pour deux raisons.
D'abord parce que
c'est quoi extrêmement forte ? C'est
quel pays ? Écoutez, les pays euh
d'Afrique de l'Ouest, d'Afrique
sub-saharienne voient leur population
pratiquement doubler encore tous les 30
30 35 ans. Donc c'est une c'est c'est
lié à ce que les familles sont sont
nombreuses. C'est lié à une augmentation
de l'espérance de vie et à la baisse de
la mortalité infantile, donc les progrès
de la médecine. Et donc pour beaucoup de
pays, c'est en fait euh la
reconnaissance que leurs efforts payent
en matière notamment de santé publique.
Et c'est une première raison pour
laquelle c'est un tabou, c'est que pour
beaucoup de pays, c'est en fait un un un
victoire que d'avoir une une une
population qui résiste si vous voulez et
et continue à croître. Deuxièmement, on
a en matière de contrôle démographique
des expériences qui ont été très
traumatisantes de contrôle des
naissances, la politique de l'enfant
unique en Chine dont ils reviennent
d'ailleurs parce que la Chine est une
société qui vieillit très vite à cause
de cette politique euh ou bien encore
sous Indera Gandhi en Inde euh des
politiques très autoritaires de contrôle
des des naissances. Et donc qu'est-ce
qu'il faut dire ? Je crois que ce qu'il
faut dire, c'est que dans certains pays,
la croissance démographique est
effectivement un vrai problème et que
pour y répondre, il faut non pas des
solutions autoritaires, mais il faut non
seulement l'accès généralisé à la
contraception, mais aussi une meilleure
éducation des femmes. Si les femmes
étudient plus longtemps, elles se
marieront plus tard et elles auront
moins d'enfants et elles auront en plus
la capacité de de de contrôler leur
fécondité beaucoup mieux parce qu'elles
auront avec un diplôme la possibilité
d'avoir un emploi à l'extérieur du du
domicile et cetera. Donc je crois que
c'est vraiment important de miser sur
l'éducation des femmes. Et puis deuxième
outil extrêmement important, c'est la
protection sociale. Une raison pour
laquelle dans des pays comme le le Mali,
le Niger euh ou le Togo, on a encore des
familles de 8 ne enfants, c'est parce
que les parents craignent pour leur
vieux jour, craignent de ne pas être
soutenus quand ils ne seront plus en
mesure de travailler et de subvenir
leurs besoins. Et donc ils ont beaucoup
d'enfants en se disant que ces enfants
vont les aider au cours de leur
vieillesse. Et donc avoir une protection
sociale performante pour rassurer les
familles sur le fait que on peut compter
sur une solidarité instituée par l'État
plutôt que sur la solidarité
intrafamiliale, ça me paraît extrêmement
important et c'est pour ça que je me
bats depuis 3 ou 4 ans, je me bats tous
les jours pour améliorer la protection
sociale dans le pays en développement.
Je pense que c'est la meilleure manière
de réduire la croissance démographique.
Et vous vous battez avec quelles armes ?
mis à part l'arme médiatique, j'ai été
regarder vos statistiques sur internet.
Votre visibilité, c'est le néant.
C'est le néant. C'est le travail des
médias que que de s'intéresser aux
questions de pauvreté qui sont des
questions un peu plombantes
qui ne paraissent pas faire l'actualité
parce que la pauvreté est avec nous
depuis très longtemps et et donc ça
n'intéresse peut-être pas tellement les
médias des statistiques qui se répètent
d'année en année, mais il faut continuer
à se battre et et un des projets que
nous avons porté avec notamment des
représentants de de la France, c'est un
projet de de fond mondial pour la
protection sociale
un mécanisme de soutien au pays en
développement pour qu'ils investissent
dans la protection sociale lorsqu'ils
n'en ont pas les moyens financiers. Et
la France était très engagée sur ce
dossier en 2020 avant de, il faut le
reconnaître, un peu se désengager.
Malheureusement, je le regrette parce
que ça pourrait être une clé pour aller
vers un développement beaucoup plus
soutenable et pour améliorer la
protection sociale dans les pays du sud.
Vous parliez de démographie, de des
enfants, de tout ça. Vous avez des
contacts avec les différentes religions
du monde ? Est-ce que si je me fais la
voc du diable ? Si j'ai huit enfants,
mais c'est la volonté de Dieu.
Écoutez, euh j'ai eu un dialogue avec le
le pape François mais que que j'ai vu à
Rome en octobre 2000 2022. Euh c'est
d'ailleurs l'origine du petit livre
changé de boussole que les éditions les
liens qui libèrent publient ces
jours-ci. Euh mais je n'ai pas un
dialogue avec les religions du monde.
Mes interlocuteurs, c'est d'abord les
gouvernements. Euh mais ce qui est vrai,
c'est que euh la les dimensions, je
dirais,
spirituelles de la transition écologique
et sociale m'intéresse beaucoup. Je
pense vraiment que la représentation
qu'on se fait du progrès du bonheur
est problématique et que si l'on
continue à se focaliser sur la
l'augmentation des possibilités de
consommation matérielle comme recette du
bonheur et comme objectif du progrès
social, l'on va vers l'échec. Il faut
une conception, je dirais, du progrès
qui soit fondé beaucoup plus sur le sur
le bien-être, sur la félicité, sur les
la qualité des rapports sociaux, l'idée
de de rapports sociaux apaisés et d'une
société réconciliée avec elle-même et et
tout cela me paraît extrêmement
important. Et c'est vrai que les les
leaders
spirituels de même que les influenceurs
ont un rôle à jouer qui n'est pas le
mien mais qui est extrêmement important.
Et et donc vous voyez ça à combien de
temps ? Parce qu'il faut à peu près quoi
? Une génération pour faire changer les
mentalités. 10 ans. C'est ça. Est-ce que
est-ce que vous pensez qu'on est sur une
bonne démarche quand on voit des
influenceurs qui se transforment en
homme sandwich pour placer des
placements produits ?
Quand on voit des rappeurs paradés avec
des super bagnoles qui font rêver les
enfants et les enfants d'autres mondes.
Qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire ? Il faut
avoir un organisme de propagande pour
faire passer les bonnes valeurs. Il faut
il faut faire quoi ? Parce que j'entends
beaucoup de choses avec la main sur le
cœur drappé dans l'étandard de la vertu.
Mais en réalité, c'est pas ça. En
réalité, on a des pays occidentaux en
récession qui sont en train pour la
majeure partie d'avoir une croissance
basée sur de la dette
des des politiques qui pour être voté
pour moi sont prêts à faire de la
subordination de vote avec les finances
publiques depuis des depuis des
décennies. Ça existe. On a c'est un peu
du wishful singing ou c'est un bon c'est
un prêche que j'entends. Si si vous me
dites que bah les seules les seules
armes que vous ayez c'est aller pleurer
dans les médias, essayer de dire voilà
bon il y a des gens qui meurent de faim,
qui meurent du tifus qui vivent avec 2 €
et des 2 dollars et des patates, je me
fais l'avoquer du diable.
Écoutez, je je pas l'impression de
servir à rien en fait.
Je ne vais je ne vais pas pleurer dans
les médias. la lacrimanie n'est pas mon
truc.
Par contre, par contre, je crois que le
discours de la sobriété
est un discours qui gagne du terrain et
que de plus en plus de gens se posent la
question de savoir si la quête du
toujours plus est véritablement la la
voix que l'on doit se donner
collectivement.
Je crois que les gens sont épuisés, ont
envie d'autre chose, réalisent que les
limites planétaires sont en train d'être
d'être largement dépassé à raison de ce
modèle de de croissance infinie que l'on
se donne et qui est complètement
irresponsable. et de plus en plus de
gens se reconnaissent dans le portrait
d'une société qui se donnerait se
donnerait des objectifs différents.
Alors euh ça veut dire euh des ça veut
dire un discours sur la transformation
qui n'est pas un discours sur le sur le
renoncement le sacrifice mais sur
la sobriété heureuse
sur la sobriété heureuse choisie qui
aujourd'hui
est la seule voix réaliste.
Est-ce qu'on va dans la bonne direction
? Oui. Est-ce qu'on va assez vite dans
ces directions ? Certainement pas. Mais
les normes sociales peuvent basculer
assez vite. On a beaucoup d'études qui
montrent et il suffit de penser à
l'impact qu'a eu le mouvement mitou sur
les rapports entre les femmes et les
hommes ou sur ou ou les rapports entre
fumeurs et et non fumeurs depuis une
vingtaine d'années. On a parfois des
normes sociales qui basculent très vite
lorsqu'une minorité consciente de la
nécessité de changer ses normes sociales
s'organise pour faire cela. Il faut pas
50 % des gens h qui changent leur
comportement pour que la norme sociale
évolue. Il suffit de de 12 15 peut-être
25 % de gens euh pour que la norme
sociale change. Et je suis convaincu
pour ma part que ce pourcentage de
personnes qui choisissent des modes de
vie différents, plus sobre, plus simple,
effectivement moins encombré de biens
matériel que cela augmente pas assez
vite mais cela augmente et que la norme
sociale va va changer bientôt. Déjà, il
est il est il est vu comme bizarre
d'avoir des voitures hyper puissantes
quand on a quand on habite en ville par
exemple et déjà il est on a honte de
prendre l'avion. Et et donc on a déjà
des comportements qui sont en train
d'évoluer euh à raison de de ce que l'on
l'on se rend compte qu'on est dans une
dans une dans une impasse, dans une
spirale mortifère dont il faut sortir.
Donc je pense qu'on va dans la bonne
direction mais je crois que la course de
vitesse qui est engagée contre la
dégradation de l'environnement, on est
en train de la perdre. On va dans la
bonne direction, on ne va pas assez
vite.
Je peux me refaire encore l'avocat du
diable ? Bien sûr.
Euh
c'est pas un un discours un peu que de
bobos qui habitent dans les capitales.
Euh des gens qui habitent en banlieu qui
crèvent la dalle. Euh là, on a vu avec
les émeutes dans les banlieux des
supermarchés qui se font braquer, des
gens qui posent avec des sacs, avec des
steaks comme un trophée dans un sac, des
gens qui vont piller des magasins pour
pouvoir ensuite peut-être faire de la
revente ou avoir accès à des biens qu'on
leur fait miroiter ou qui leur permet
d'avoir un rang social ou de donner
l'illusion de d'être sorti de la
pauvreté. Je vous tends la perche pour
que vous puissiez rebondir sur votre
préféré.
Donc le discours qu'on peut avoir là,
c'est pas un discours de bobo. Les gens
qui sont déjà dans la pauvreté, une
grande majeure partie euh sont déjà en
décroissance
euh on ont une conscience de de du la
dégradation de la de la de la planète ou
des ressources.
Ouais.
Mais après moi, le déluge.
Ouais. Ouais.
Comment on fait pour faire passer ça ?
Moi, je suis convaincu en tout cas que
le discours écologiste ne passe
absolument pas auprès des des classes
populaires et des populations issues de
l'immigration récente en particulier.
Absolument pas. J'en suis parfaitement
conscient. Je salue d'ailleurs à cet
égard le travail de de Fatima Wass avec
qui j'étais en dialogue il y a une
semaine autour de son livre pour une
écologie pirate et et je crois que
l'apport de Fatima Wass à ce recherche
d'un discours sur l'écologie est
absolument important parce que cela
oblige à adopter une perspective
différente et on a on ne peut tenir un
discours convainquant sur l'écologie
qu'en y associant une pluralité de
perspective. Voilà, pour ma part, je
travaille beaucoup avec des gens issus
de la grande pauvreté.
J'ai suivi de très près le travail qui a
débouché sur un rapport intitulé
durabilité et pauvreté
en Belgique où ATD Carmonde a joué un
rôle tout à fait décisif. Et ce que je
constate, c'est que les personnes en
pauvreté euh sont
euh euh fatiguées euh qu'on leur dise
"Écoutez, vous c'est c'est la malbouffe,
vous c'est c'est la consommation
irresponsable, vous c'est la c'est la
quête du plus et et et des
préoccupations purement matérielles." Et
et ces populations là ont absolument
besoin de participer aux solutions. Je
crois qu'une des grandes raisons pour
lesquelles on est en train d'échouer
aujourd'hui à faire évoluer la société,
c'est qu'on le fait de manière très
descendante, top down si vous voulez,
technocratique, autoritaire parfois
alors qu'on pourrait le faire ou on
devrait le faire de manière
participative et horizontale. Et je
crois que c'est vraiment une grammaire
du pouvoir qu'il faut changer. est à
condition de faire les choses avec les
populations et notamment les plus
marginalisées qui se sentent non
représenté incomprises que l'on peut
faire évoluer les choses à la fois parce
que c'est une manière d'avancer de
manière beaucoup plus légitime et et et
de ne pas rencontrer de résistances mais
c'est aussi une manière plus
intelligente d'opérer parce qu'on
comprend beaucoup mieux alors les
obstacles que les gens rencontrent, les
souhaits qu'ils ouell expriment les
objectifs qui se fixent dans dans leur
vie. Et donc la participation me paraît
absolument clé et je ne crois pas qu'on
puisse construire la transformation
écologique de nos sociétés sans une
radicalisation de la démocratie. Et pas
seulement en démocratisant l'État, les
structures publiques, mais aussi en
démocratisant la société. C'est-à-dire
que dans les entreprises, dans les
universités, dans les écoles, il faut
beaucoup plus associer les personnes
concernées euh et et non seulement
écouter ces personnes, mais leur
permettre de construire les solutions.
On parlait de proposition politique. On
voit [raclement de gorge] que en France
et en Europe, les vols de nourriture ont
augmenté depuis le l'inflation d à tout
un tas de facteurs. la guerre, la
production monétaire à outrance,
l'injection de liquidité et j'en passe à
la sortie du Covid aussi.
Comment
quand on a je me demande je demande à
fac checké quand on a en France environ
25 % des moins de 25 ans en privation
alimentaire importante voire grave,
comment la chaîne politique pourquoi la
chaîne politique ne réagit pas quand on
voit les restaurants du cœur augmenter,
être sous l'eau ? parce qu'il y a de
plus en plus de demandes de gens qu'ils
avaient jamais vu.
Quand on a faim, c'est compliqué de de
lancer une population vers un un nouvel
objectif.
Mais bien sûr, il faut commencer par
l'essentiel. Et don les les personnes en
en difficulté à à avoir un un pouvoir
d'achat qui leur permet de vivre
dignement. Ça me paraît ça me paraît
évident et je dirais d'ailleurs de ce
point de vue-là, j'ai j'ai interpellé la
France à ce à ce à ce propos que le fait
d'avoir un RSA, un revenu de solidarité
active dont ne bénéficie pas les jeunes
de moins de 25 ans est absolument
injustifiable et c'est un combat que je
conduis depuis des depuis des années. Je
je je ne m'explique pas que l'on ne
revienne pas là-dessus. la France très
isolé dans dans ce sur cette question
euh par rapport à d'autres pays
européens
et pas que ça he
mais donc il faut il faut évidemment
euh prendre au sérieux cette crise du
pouvoir d'achat qui est un un un drame
pour beaucoup de familles qui étaient à
la limite et qui aujourd'hui sont en
dessous de la limite. Et d'ailleurs,
rappelons quand même que ce sont
l'énergie et l'alimentation qui ont vu
leur prix augmenter le plus avec
l'inflation. tout à fait extraordinaire,
inédite depuis 1973 à laquelle on
assistéit en 2022.
Formidable
et c'est comment dites-vous ?
Formidable de formida terrifiant.
Absolument. Et donc c'est c'est c'est
l'alimentation, l'énergie dont les prix
ont le plus augmenté. Or, ce sont dans
les ménages dans les dans les budgets
des ménages précaires, ce sont deux
postes plus importants que pour des
ménages qui sont plus à l'aise
financièrement. Donc c'est cette
inflation, elle elle est elle est elle
est dramatique. La l'érosion du pouvoir
d'achat qui en est résulté est
dramatique quand les salaires et les
prestations sociales ne s'adaptent pas.
Et je regrette que cela ne se fasse pas
de manière régulière et systématique.
Alors, on va parler euh un un temps des
prestations sociales. Euh il y a
énormément de gens qui ne réclament pas
leurs prestations sociales euh alors
qu'ils sont éligibles à Il y a une autre
partie qui fait de la fraude sociale, il
y a une autre partie qui fait de
l'évasion fiscale.
D'ailleurs, l'évasion fiscale représente
une montagne face à la fraude sociale.
Mais bon, on préfère se se polariser sur
la fraude sociale.
Ça doit être populiste, ça doit
galvaniser les gens pour faire voter.
Comment
?
D'accord. Et donc entre 80 et 100
milliards d'évasion fiscale. Merci à ma
gauche, mon cerveau de gauche.
C'est aussi des économie parce que si
les gens réclament pas
alors la la question
je me suis dur hein.
La question Sky que vous évoquez est
super importante. J'ai consacré tutoyer
Olivier.
On se tuto bien volontiers. La question
donc que tu poses Sky est extrêmement
importante et j'ai consacré un rapport
présenté aux Nations- Unies à cette
question du non recours au droit. En
France, je donne simplement ce chiffre
là, 34 % seulement des personnes ayant
droit au RSA le réclament. 34 % donc un
peu plus d'un tiers c'est inoui. Ça veut
dire que euh ça veut dire que 66 % 60
euh
Oui, c'est ça. 62 % des 64 %
pardonnez-moi euh des des des personnes
qui ont droit au RSA ne le réclament
pas. Pourquoi ? [grognement] Parce que
ce sont des gens qui craignent les
contacts avec les services sociaux. Je
connais des familles en pauvreté qui
craignent qu'on retire l'enfant du foyer
si l'enfant est considélé comme un
risque parce que ce sont des ménages qui
vivent en grande pauvreté. Ce sont des
personnes qui euh euh ne sont pas
informées quant à leur droit. Ce sont
des personnes qui ont eu des expériences
traumatisantes avec les services sociaux
et qui ne veulent pas revivre ces
expériences et donc se tiennent à l'abri
des contacts ou bien ce sont des
personnes qui ne manient pas internet
facilement, ne peuvent pas remplir la
demande en ligne et cetera et et par
conséquent ne réclame pas ces ces ses
droits et et il en va du RSA comme il en
va de la location familiale, la location
de chômage et cetera.
C'est par dignité aussi. C'està-dire
qu'ils estiment que réclamer comme ça,
c'est une perte de dignité. Ça veut dire
que là, ils prennent conscience qu'ils
sont dans une extrême pauvreté. Il y a
une partie de ces de la population qui
entend ce discours qui
culpabilise les personnes en pauvreté,
qui leur reprochent leur situation, qui
imputent aux pauvres eux-mêmes la
responsabilité de leurs conditions et ce
sont des personnes qui ont effectivement
honte
et et craignent la stigmatisation qui
résulterait de ce qu'il de ce qu'il
demande par exemple à bénéficier de
d'allocation.
logement ou d'allocation familiale. Donc
il y a ça aussi. Mais c'est surtout dans
les sondages auxquels j'ai pu avoir
accès et dans l'étude que j'ai faite,
c'est surtout la question de du manque
d'information de de la lourdeur des
obstacles administratifs et c'est lié à
la lutte contre la fraude. On a
tellement peur de la fraude qu'on
multiplie les obstacles à l'accès aux
aides et que finalement ce sont les
personnes en pauvreté qui ont les plus
besoins d'aide qui ne parviennent pas à
franchir ce parcours d'obstacle et se
sentent finalement exclus. Et de manière
paradoxale, on a donc un système de
protection sociale qui aide une partie
de la population certainement mais ne
parvient pas à aider les personnes les
plus marginalisées parce que ces
obstacles que l'on rencontre dans le
parcours d'obstacles administratifs pour
avoir accès au Z,
il est surtout difficile à à à parcourir
pour les personnes en pauvreté.
Pardon ? Parce que il y a aussi de la
fraude.
La fraude existe mais elle est minimale
par rapport à la réalité du non recours
au droit. Et euh les chiffres montrent
que on on on surestime la fraude par
rapport à ce phénomène massif du non
recours droit. Et donc arrêtons de de
croire que la fraude est un grand
problème. C'est très
peu d'argent par rapport seulement à
l'évasion fiscale mais surtout au non
recours droit.
Une coupure de presse du Parisien. En 1
an, le montant total des allocations
touchées illégalement augmenté de 13,5
%. 351 millions d'euros, c'est le
montant record de fraude et allocation
familiale détecté en 2022.
Oui, ben écoutez, les médias aiment
faire le leur leur leur première leur
leur une ou leur ou leur titre sur sur
ces questions de fraude.
Pourquoi ? Mais je crois que c'est
simplement une sorte de stéréotype euh à
propos des allocataires sociaux que l'on
entretient bien volontiers et ça
entretient la la défiance sociale et et
la le la haine du pauvre si vous voulez.
Ça me paraît pas très responsable.
J'aimerais que les médias parlent
beaucoup plus du non recours au droit et
les chiffres seraient beaucoup plus
impressionnants. Ils mériteraient eux de
faire la une.
Là en ce moment, on traverse une période
très difficile en France avec les
émeutes qu'il y a en banlieu parisienne
et ailleurs d'ailleurs. La France des
banlieux sans bras
dû à un gamin derrière le volant d'une
grosse voiture qui a été descendue ou
tuée par un policier. Euh
[raclement de gorge] on attend les
suites de l'enquête. D'ailleurs,
comment vous expliquez ça ? Est-ce que
vous craignez que euh non pas pas le
fait que il y ait eu un accident, mais
est-ce que vous craignez des émeutes des
pauvres ? Est-ce que à partir d'un
certain point quand il y a tellement de
pauvreté, les gens disent maintenant ça
suffit
et
et sous quelle façon ça va se, on va
dire matérialiser ? Est-ce que ça va
être des rapines, des descentes dans les
les endroits très riches ? Est-ce que
comment ça va se matérialiser ?
Écoutez, je je je n'en sais rien et je
ne suis pas de vin. Je constate une
croissance de l'impatience. La
population des personnes en précarité
cependant est très hétérogène et
comment vous la mesurez la croissance de
l'impatience ?
J'entends ce discours de de
de gens fatigués qu'on qu'on ne
comprennent pas leur leur plainte par
rapport au pouvoir d'achat et le fait
que la pauvreté ne soit pas
vu comme un comme un scandale dont les
gouvernements doivent s'occuper
d'urgence. Donc les gens se sentent en
fait abandonnés et on a l'impression que
les appels qui étaient ceux de de de
l'abé Pierre en 1954 ou du père Joseph
Rinski un peu plus tard dans les années
50 et 60
sont des appels qui aujourd'hui
ne sont plus entendus et la je dirais
que l'indignation
par rapport à la pauvreté a disparu. On
est plus scandalisé par ça. On s'est
habitué à ce que les personnes en
pauvreté fassent partie du paysage, que
le sans-abrisme continue d'exister, que
des des personnes
mal nourries
soient encore tolérés dans une Europe
pourtant très prospère et cetera. Donc
on s'habitue à cela et je et et et cela
les gens effectivement ne le ne le
comprennent pas et expriment leur
impatience. Mais les personnes en
pauvreté sont très hétérogènes, sont mal
organisées, sont souvent isolées les
unes des autres et ne font pas masse, si
vous voulez, au point de pouvoir
protester. Et en plus, on exige des
pauvres une certaine euh docilité. Et
euh je crois que euh beaucoup de
personnes en pauvreté ont l'impression
qu'on va leur reprocher de
euh de de recourir à des protestations
surtout si celle-ci dérape alors même
qu'elles se sentent en dette puisque ell
elle ell elles veulent obtenir des
allocations sociales, des soutiens et
cetera. Donc il est très difficile pour
ces personnes en fait de se mobiliser et
elles sont elles sont par rapport à
d'autres groupes sociaux relativement
relativement mal organisé. Moi je je
j'appelle à des à des protestations qui
soient pas à faire des protestations
qui soient aussi ludiques. Je je je
donne simplement un exemple qui qui que
j'aime beaucoup Sky de ce que l'on
pourrait imaginer.
On on
on on a un chômage structurel des des
chômeurs et chômeuses de longue durée
encore trop nombreux. Et bien
que ces personnes fassent un jour la
grève du chômage et qu'elle travaille
pour la collectivité en montrant combien
il y a du travail à faire
que l'on pourrait leur donner.
En Italie, on a eu cela des chômeurs et
chômeuses de longue durée qui ont décidé
de travailler en guise de protestation
en montrant que beaucoup de besoins
sociaux n'étaient pas satisfaits. Euh la
petite enfance n'est pas bien prise en
charge. On ne s'occupe pas assez des des
des personnes très âgées et dépendantes.
On ne on ne on ne s'occupe pas assez des
communs et et de et de et d'entretenir
les parts publics et cetera. Et il y a
plein de besoins sociétaux qui ne sont
pas satisfaits et en même temps, on a
beaucoup de gens qui n'ont pas de
travail et c'est pour dénoncer cette ce
paradoxe et cette inéquité que en Italie
on a fait cette grève du chômage. Et je
pense que c'est ce genre d'action
ludique qui peut peut-être attirer mieux
l'attention sur la question de pauvreté.
surtout pas de violence, c'est ça.
Mais en tout cas, je ne je ne je ne
pense pas que les personnes au pauvreté
euh soient euh euh dans cette euh dans
cet état d'espritlà de recourir à la
violence pour se faire entendre. Et je
ne crois pas en plus que ce soit la la
voix euh qui permettra de euh je dirais
de convaincre l'opinion publique qu'il
faut faire quelque chose. Euh euh je je
je crois que le risque serait alors que
l'opinion publique euh au contraire voit
cette ce précaria comme une classe
dangereuse qu'il faut contrôler avec
davantage de policiers et pas avec des
aides sociales. Et c'est ce qu'on subit
aux États-Unis par exemple. Vous savez,
aux États-Unis, on a un état providence
qui a reculé beaucoup et à la place, on
a un état pénal qui est venu
contrôler
ces populations, cadriant le territoire
de policier, augmentant la population
pénitentiaire de manière dramatique. Ce
que documente le sociologue Loï Wakan,
par exemple à l'université de de
Berkley. Et c'est cela que l'on court
comme risque si l'on va vers des actions
plus violentes. Vous parliez de pouvoir
d'achat, maintenant on parle de reste à
vivre.
Ouais.
C'est c'est dingue quand même, non ?
Oui. Écoutez, il y a des populations qui
manquent de tout et
qui subissent d'autant plus les impacts
d'un pouvoir d'achat suffisant que la
société est de plus en plus
marchandisée. Euh toute une série de
services euh auxquels on avait accès par
le passé gratuitement. sont aujourd'hui
marchandisés. Il faut de plus en plus
dans ces loisirs payer tout ce que l'on
fait, tout ce que l'on consomme.
Et et et et même ce qui est en principe
gratuit comme par exemple l'école euh en
fait coûte cher au ménage parce qu'il
faut payer le transport, parce qu'il
faut payer euh le matériel scolaire,
parce qu'il faut payer les les le la
semaine verte à l'école et les vacances
scolaires et cetera. Et donc
les classes vertes, on dit en France
pour on classe on dit les classes vertes
en France. On on on a donc des des
populations entières qui se sentent
marginalisé et pour qui l'absence de
pouvoir d'achat suffisant est
extrêmement pénalisant, beaucoup plus
que cela n'était le cas il y a une
trentaine d'années en raison de cette
marchandisation généralisée euh des
services et des biens.
Les aides aux soins comme le dentiste,
le déremboursement des soins dentaires
et des choses comme ça. Il nous arrive
ça en France. Question internet.
Serait-il enable envisageable d'imaginer
des gens entre parenthèses pacifistes en
sécession un genre de système auto géré
avec des micromonnaies type la Zade zone
à défendre mais à différentes échelles ?
Oui, je crois que dans
si vous voulez la génération actuelle,
on est un peu fatigué des modes
classiques de mobilisation. On ne milite
plus guerre dans les partis politiques,
dans les syndicats, même dans les ONG et
l'on est à la recherche d'autres
manières de se faire entendre. Et parmi
ces autres manières de se faire
entendre, il y a euh l'organisation
d'autres euh possibles, euh l'occupation
de zones à défendre, le développement de
nouvelles manières de produire et de
consommer, les coopératives d'énergie
citoyenne, les circuits courts en
matière d'alimentation et cetera. Ce
sont, si vous voulez, des manières de
protester contre l'injonction de
consommer que nous fait la société de
consommation et ce sont euh c'est
l'invention d'autres manières de vivre.
Et et ce que je trouve remarquable et
très encourageant en réalité, c'est que
c'est un mode de protestation qui
aujourd'hui est de plus en plus commun.
Euh la génération à laquelle moi
j'enseigne à l'université, les jeunes
qui ont 25 et 30 ans, ce sont des pour
quel tarif ?
Comment
vous enseignez pour quel salaire ?
Euh moi, je suis bien payé pour ce que
je fais à l'université.
Euh en Belgique, on a le grand bénéfice
de voir des salaires indexé en fonction
du du coût de la vie. Et donc, j'ai un
salaire qui est aujourd'hui euh en en
nette de 5600 par mois. Donc, je suis
très bien payé. Euh et j'enseigne à des
jeunes qui se mobilisent, je m'en
réjouis et ils sont euh euh ils sont non
seulement dans la dans la protestation
et dans la pétition, mais aussi dans le
faire. C'est-à-dire qu'ils invent
alternatives qui créent d'autres
possibles.
Question d'internet, tu me l'affiches.
Impeccable.
Question : N'avez-vous pas l'impression
d'être l'instrument, l'intello utile de
pouvoir dont les finalités ne sont pas
les vôtres et dont la grammaire est à
l'opposé de l'horizontalité louable que
vous défendez ?
Est-ce que
Ouais, écoutez, la question est
légitime, mais ma ma démarche et je
dirait même mon éthique dans la manière
dont je dont je dont je pratique la
mobilisation autour de ces questions de
pauvreté euh
consiste à créer un espace dont d'autres
peuvent peuvent s'emparer. Et j'ai
beaucoup travaillé par le passé sur les
questions d'alimentation. Et là, j'ai
voulu faire un espace pour que les
droits des paysans, la souveraineté
alimentaire
puisse s'exprimer à travers la parole
des personnes qui sont dans
l'agriculture paysane, dans
l'agroécologie et cetera. Et de la même
manière, je ne prétends pas me
substituer aux personnes en pauvreté
pour en être le porte-parole ou
l'ambassadeur.
Je j'essaie de convaincre les
gouvernements et d'ailleurs tous les
acteurs qui comptent dans la société
d'associer ces personnes à la prise de
décision pour qu'elles puissent non
seulement faire valoir leur point de vue
et être consulté mais participer à la
prise de décision. Et donc euh j'essaie
de créer des espaces qu'il revient alors
à d'autres d'occuper et c'est cela mon
rôle en fait. Euh vous parliez
d'agriculture paysane.
Est-ce que vous pensez que l'agriculture
paysane peut nourrir notre population ?
Mais l'agriculture paysane à faible
usage d'un trans avec des méthodes
agroécologiques qui permettent de de de
préserver de renforcer la santé des
sols. Elle est très productive à
l'hectare. Elle est très productive à
l'hectare en terme de d'autres par
surface. très vulnérable au aux
différentes vermines. Non, parce qu'on a
des méthodes de contrôle biologique où
les plantes peuvent se protéger les unes
les autres par un par des cultures
associées, par des rotations de culture
qui permettent au contraire d'être
beaucoup plus résilient par rapport à la
fois au au aux insectes ravageurs ou au
choc climatique. Donc c'est une
agriculture résiliente et performante.
Le problème, c'est que c'est une
agriculture qui repose sur
un une utilisation de la main d'œuvre
beaucoup plus intensive et donc qui est
plus cher. de combien ? Mais
écoutez, c'est pas possible de donner un
chiffre comme ça, mais comme il faut
plus de main d'œuvre, euh il faut pour
que les paysans et paysanes soient
dignement rémunérés, il faut payer plus
cher notre alimentation si on généralise
la pratique agroécologique ou le recours
aux pratiques agroécologiques. Je suis
un grand partisan de cela. Je crois
qu'il faut qu'on accepte de payer plus
cher les paysans et paysanes qui
pratiquent ce métier extrêmement noble
et il faut les encourager à aller vers
des méthodes de production qui sont plus
intensives en main d'œuvre et moins
intensies en intran chimique. Mais cela
signifie qu'il faut attacher plus
importance à notre alimentation et
protéger les ménages précaires en
subsidiant bien davantage ce type
d'agriculture là. Alors qu'aujourd'hui
l'essentiel des subventions que l'on
verse aux agriculteurs, c'est des
subventions qui favorisent l'agriculture
conventionnelle, chimique à haute
intensité d'intre-productive,
détruisant la santé des sols et
réduisant la fertilité naturelle des
sols.
Qu'est-ce que les Nations- Unies
prêchent concernant l'évasion fiscale,
le dumping dumping fiscal ?
Alors
quand vous avez dit que la France était
isolée
sur sur la taxe sur les transactions
financières, on est isolé, on n'est pas
isolé, est-ce que la France a pris des
positions claires ? Est-ce que vous en
avez entendu parler ?
Non, je je je j'évoquais le fait que la
France était un cas isolé par rapport au
RSA n'allant pas aux jeunes de moins de
25 ans. Et c'est vrai que c'est un c'est
assez rare que les États choisissent euh
d'écarter les jeunes adultes de ce de de
du revenu minimum. Euh en ce qui
concerne l'évasion fiscale,
le message des Nations unies est effect
évidemment qu'il faut lutter contre elle
de manière beaucoup plus énergique et
une série de
consultations ont régulièrement lieu
pour que les États se concertent entre
eux pour faire bien davantage. Le vrai
problème, c'est des États qui refusent
de jouer le jeu,
abritent des paradis fiscaux.
Mais écoutez, je suis très frappé par
exemple de ce que quand le Royaume-Uni
est passé devant le comité des droits
économiques, socioculturels lorsque j'en
était membre en en 2016,
le Royaume-Uni, à propos des îles
Caillement, à propos de l'île de Man et
cetera, des des des îles
sous-juridiction britanniques, la
réponse du Royaume-Uni est que dans le
système britannique, on ne peut pas
imposer à ces paradis fiscaux une
quelconque discipline, ce qui me paraît
tout à fait inacceptable. [musique]
Euh tant que il y aura des paradis
fiscaux, euh tant que l'opacité
financière sera entretenue par certains
États, il va continuer d'être difficile
de lutter contre l'évation fiscale. Et
puis beaucoup de pays en développement
n'ont pas les moyens de véritablement
lutter contre cela parce que leur leurs
systèmes administratifs ne sont pas
assez robustes. Et donc, il faut aider
ces pays à faire bien davantage contre
l'évasion fiscale. C'est tout à fait
scandaleux. Rappelons tout de même que
euh beaucoup plus d'argent quittent ces
pays en développement à travers des
mécanismes d'ingénierie fiscale et
d'évision fiscale qu'il n'arrive dans
ces pays grâce à l'aide publique au
développement. Donc c'est tout à fait
euh bizarre comme situation et il y a
des pays qui sont effectivement
responsables de cela, qui entretiennent
ces paradis fiscaux.
Comment les Nations- Unies se
positionnent sur le fait que la France
et l'Allemagne et est poussé, milité
pour pouvoir injecter des spyware sur
les téléphones des journalistes ?
Comment vous vous le percevez ça ? Quand
quand un état, [grognement] c'est parce
que on le faisait avant et maintenant il
faut que ce soit légal. C'est parce que
les États anticipent que les
journalistes aillent lever des choses
qui pourraient pour raison d'état
déranger. Donc pour raison d'état, on
injecte des spyware sur leur leur div et
c'est une question légitime et je
comprends qu'elle te préoccupe mais je
ne connais pas cette question à laquelle
sur laquelle je n'ai jamais je ne me
suis jamais penché en détail. Donc je
n'ai rien à dire de d'intéressant en
tant qu'homme,
non mais moi je trouve ça effectivement
extrêmement inquiétant que des que des
logiciel qui dont l'usage peut-être
justifié par des services de
renseignement ou pour lutter contre la
criminalité organisée servent à
espionner des journalistes ou des
opposants politiques. On a d'ailleurs eu
un un scandale majeur en Grèce et je ne
comprends pas que le que le gouvernement
grec de Mitsoakis n'ait pas été
sanctionné par les électeurs à la suite
de ce scandale. Quel était le scandale ?
Explique un peu.
Non, le scandale, c'est que des des des
journalistes critiques du gouvernement
ont été euh euh espionné euh à travers
des logiciels, le logiciel Pegasus, en
particulier euh si je me rappelle bien
en Grèce. Mais mais voilà, je n'ai pas
étudié ce dossier des prêts donc je n'ai
pas de commentaires très intéressants à
donner.
Est-ce que tu veux aborder un sujet en
particulier entre tr toi, toi et nous ?
Qu'est-ce que Quel est le sujet que tu
souhaites aborder en priorité qui n'est
pas assez traité dans les médias
mis à part ton sujet ? Mais non, mon
travail porte sur la pauvreté depuis
quelques années et je vais m'investir
dans les années qui viennent à à
identifier comment l'on peut lutter
contre la pauvreté sans reposer sur la
sur la croissance. Jusqu'à présent, la
manière dont dont on a lutté contre la
croissance était très simple et
classique, c'est qu'on a augmenté la
richesse monétaire par toute une série
de politiques que je crois extrêmement
problématique euh qu'on pourrait
détailler. Et à travers cette
augmentation de la richesse monétaire,
on a euh imposé des des taxes aux
entreprises et aux ménages les plus les
plus riches pour financer les services
publics et la protection sociale. Et
cette manière de lutter contre la
pauvreté, elle montre aujourd'hui ses
limites. Elle elle ne elle ne parvient
plus à réduire la pauvreté comme il le
faudrait.
Tu dis ça parce qu'on t'objecte souvent
le fait que bah la mondialisation a
sorti énormément de gens de la pauvreté,
que il y a beaucoup moins de gens dans
la pauvreté. C'est ça.
Alors c'est vrai que la mondialisation
des années 80 90 a permis à certains
pays de faire des progrès considérables
en matière de réduction de la pauvreté.
C'est le cas notamment de la Chine et de
plusieurs pays d'Asie, du Sud et du
Sud-Est, y compris l'Inde dans une
moindre mesure. Euh mais la pauvreté euh
demeure extrêmement importante dans
beaucoup de régions du monde et elle a
même progressé dans certaines régions au
cours de cette même période de
mondialisation extrêmement forte. Donc
elle a été la solution pour quelques
pays, mais certainement pas pour tous
les pays. Et les écarts de richesse
entre euh les populations pauvres et
riches au sein des pays, ces écarts ont
augmenté. La mondisation en fait
augmenté les inégalités parce que la
manière dont euh euh elle elle a opéré,
c'est que euh il y a eu des gagnants
mais aussi des perdants dans le fait de
la de mettre en concurrence les
économies du monde. Donc la modélisation
a eu certains impacts positifs, il ne
faut pas le nier, mais elle a fragilisé
beaucoup de population et dans les pays
riches, elle a notamment marginalisé les
travailleurs et travailleuses faiblement
diplômées, soumis à la concurrence
internationale, menacé par les
délocalisations et par le chantage dans
l'emploi que pratiquent les grandes
entreprises. Dans un pays comme les
États-Unis, pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'humanité, on a vu
l'espérance de vie chuter pour les
travailleurs et travailleuses pauvres.
C'est ce qu' ont bien montré Anne K et
Angus Diton dans un ouvrage qui
s'appelle Mort de désespoir où il montre
que les travailleurs faiblement
qualifiés aux États-Unis,
notamment blanc ont vu leur espérance de
vie chuter en raison de l'usage de
drogues, d'opioïdes, en raison de
suicide, en raison de l'alcoolisme. Ce
sont des personnes désespérées et qui
avec avec la robotisation et avec la
modélisation se sentent complètement
marginalisé. Et effectivement, c'est ce
qui explique le vote populiste, le vote
de Trump, c'est ce qui explique aussi le
Brexit au Royaume-Uni. Et c'est
extrêmement important que nous prenions
conscience de ce que la mondisation,
bien qu'elle est, réduit la pauvreté
dans certains pays, notamment en Asie
euh du Sud-Est,
a été pour beaucoup de populations euh
extrêmement difficile à gérer.
Question semi-internet. Euh vous avez
dit plutôt qu'il faut construire des
appartements et logements sociaux à côté
des lieux avec du travail, de la culture
et des services publics. Est-ce qu'il
faut abandonner les campagnes ou amener
aussi la culture et le travail dans ces
endroits ?
Oui.
Écoutez, c'est évidemment
une question super importante et en
France il y a ces clivages géographiques
euh très net entre les
qu'en France.
Oui, mais en France, c'est un thème qui
revient souvent, les inégalités
territoriales et c'est une bonne chose
qu'on en parle parce qu'elles sont
réelles. On a en France euh des ghetaos,
on a en France des périphéries qui sont
oubliées des centre-villes avec des
centre-villes qui ont traversé une
gentrification extrêmement importante et
on a des zones rurales qui sont
délaissées et c'est un thème important
dans les débats publics français. Je
pense qu'on peut se réjouir de ce que ce
thème soit au moins abordé parce qu'il
est une une réalité dans la vie
quotidienne des gens. Euh voilà. Alors,
je je n'ai je je sais que c'est quelque
chose qui voilà préoccupe beaucoup de
gens en France, que par exemple
France Service veut décentraliser
l'accès au services publics pour les
populations rurales et et que c'est
quelque chose qui qui progresse. Mais
voilà, moi je ne connais pas bien la
situation en France. Mon mandat étant
malheureusement à l'échelle à l'échelle
mondiale, je n'ai jamais étudié la
France en détail. D'ailleurs, la France
est un pays où je n'ai jamais fait de
mission officielle euh que j'ai faite
dans d'autres pays. Méfiez-vous, vous
risquez d'être qualifié de terrorista
euh sociolo attention hein. Euh je vais
vous poser des questions sur
l'intelligence artificielle et des
répercussions sur le travail et de des
répercussions sur bah les pauvres qui
vont risque de se faire manger par tout
ça sur le crédit social à la chinoise.
Et puis je vais vous poser des questions
sur le Malaoui et les brochettes de rat
et l'hyperinflation au Mala et je vais
vous poser aussi des questions sur le
fait est-ce que vous faites des
cauchemars ? Donc commençons par
l'intelligence artificielle. Est-ce que
les Nations- Unies ont pris la mesure
des répercussions de l'intelligence
artificielle sur les travailleurs
pauvres ? Est-ce que ça va générer
encore plus de pauvreté ? Est-ce que on
prévoit aux Nations- Unies un salaire
universel
jusqu'à ce que bah les pauvres
s'éteignent ou les pauvres soient mis à
l'PPAD ou les pauvres est-ce qu'on va
avoir des préconisations ? Je me fais
l'avocat du diable, je vous vois de
liner de la tête et sourire.
Est-ce qu'on va
avoir des aides pour que les plus
pauvres comprennent et puissent
interagir avec l'intelligence
artificielle ? Je t'écoute Olivier. Non,
on a des projections qui montrent que
l'automatisation des tâches, la
robotisation et plus encore avec
l'intelligence artificiel, ça va amener
des destructions d'emploi importantes et
cela va amener plus d'un milliard de
postes de travail à évoluer. Donc même
les personnes qui resteront en poste
vont devoir s'adapter à à des nouvelles
manières de travailler à raison des
progrès technologiques.
Ce qui m'inquiète dans ce développement,
c'est que le pouvoir de négociation des
travailleurs et travailleuses va
effectivement être gravement affaibli et
l'on estime, c'est une projection que
l'on a que d'ici 2030
[grognement]
les salaires enfin la progression des
salaires va être réduite de 2 % à raison
de l'automatisation des tâches. Et donc
cela rejoint ce qu'on disait il y a une
minute sur les travaux de H Angus Diton,
c'est que l'automatisation des tâches
rend les travailleurs et travailleuses
faiblement qualifié redondant et et et
les expose à une concurrence non
seulement de de de salariés mal
rémunérés dans les dans les pays du sud,
ce qui était déjà le cas depuis les
années 80, mais aussi une concurrence
avec les machines et c'est
ce sont de très nombreux emplois qui
sont qui sont ainsi menacés et pour je
dirais le la santé mentale des
travailleurs et travailleux, savoir
qu'on peut être remplacé par une
machine, c'est extrêmement
problématique. Donc c'est quelque chose
qui doit nous préoccuper. N'oublions pas
que on a notamment en Afrique une
croissance démographique qui devient qui
demeure importante et on estime que dans
les pays en développement 470 millions
de jeunes adultes vont arriver sur le
marché du travail d'ici 2035. Donc il
faudra trouver les emplois pour ces
gens-là. Et donc on doit se demander si
c'est
je dirais cette
euh cette cette course à la à la
l'automatisation des tâches est bien
raisonnable. Est-ce que ce n'est pas
finalement
est-ce que le moment n'est pas venu de
réfléchir à l'opportunité de de l'otch
qui crée de l'emploi et qui permettent
peut-être de réduire aussi l'impact
énergétique de nos modes de production
et de consommation ?
Le crédit social à la chinoise.
Qu'est-ce que tu en penses ?
Alors, c'est bien, c'est pas bien, ça va
nous servir.
Il me semble que c'est euh
annonciateur d'évolution dont nos
sociétés ne sont pas préservées. On va
avoir de plus en plus une centralisation
des informations concernant chaque
individu dans des banques données, dans
des banques de données qui seront de
plus en plus
je dirais
outillé pour centraliser des
informations sur sur les individus et et
et on a par ailleurs euh un phénomène
qui existe depuis une quinzaine d'années
dans les pays riches, c'est le phénomène
de de l'activisation de l'activation
pardon des prestations sociales.
C'est-à-dire qu'on on accorde des
soutiens, des allocations
de plus en plus sous condition aux
individus. Notamment, ils doivent suivre
des formations, ils doivent accepter le
travail qui leur est proposé, ils
doivent accepter de se faire suivre
suivre des thérapies et cetera pour être
plus employable à la suite de ces de ces
consultations qu'ils conduisent ou des
formations qu'ils reçoivent. Et donc euh
je je je crois que de plus en plus on va
vers des sociétés où les individus
seront jugés, évalués, leur performance
quantifié en permanence euh pour euh au
fond que l'on euh que que l'on
subordonne l'accès à la communauté euh
au respect de certaines conditions.
C'est vers ça qu'on va et je pense que
la Chine de ce point de vue-là annonce
ce qui risque de se généraliser dans les
années qui viennent dans nos sociétés.
Je te pose une question.
Est-ce que c'est faire preuve de Est-ce
que c'est être en bonne santé que d'être
bien adapté à une société profondément
malade ?
Je je suis partisan moi d'une sociité.
Je suis partisan d'une société où
différents modes de vie sont non
seulement tolérés mais encouragés et où
l'on crée des espaces que les gens
puissent utiliser comme lieu
d'expérimentation pour vivre autrement.
Et donc oui, je trouve
sain que certains se donnent comme
objectif de sortir de ce couple travail
consommation tout à fait mortifère. Et
euh je crois qu'il faut donner à ces
gens-là les moyens de euh de poursuivre
leur propre conception de la vie bonne.
C'est la raison pour laquelle euh
les expériences autour d'un revenu de
base euh par exemple un revenu de base
inconditionnel accordé à tous et toutes
sans autres conditions
ou sans sans une quelconque condition
m'intéresse. J'ai préconisé que tous les
jeunes de 18 à 25 ans puissent avoir
accès à un revenu de base sans condition
parce que c'est l'âge auquel l'on doit
permettre aux jeunes de poursuivre des
études, de poursuivre leur passion, de
faire des métiers qui les intéressent
sans être nécessairement obligé de faire
des métiers qui permettent d'avoir une
rémunération suffisante pour fonder un
foyer, pour avoir accès à un appartement
et cetera. Et donc si on pouvait
commencer par un revenu de base pour les
jeunes de 18 à 25 ans pour éviter que
les [raclement de gorge] jeunes nés dans
des familles euh riches soient
privilégiés par rapport aux jeunes nés
dans des ménages précaires, je pense que
ce serait tout à fait important et c'est
à ce moment-là qu'on peut le mieux
briser ces je dirais cette transmission
intergénérationnelle de la pauvreté à
laquelle on assiste encore beaucoup trop
dans un pays comme la France.
le réchauffement climatique, les
migrations, les gens qui vont avoir des
problèmes pour produire leur
alimentation d à la remontée du sel les
terres agricoles.
C'est combien de personnes ? À combien
de temps ça représente ? Un choc, un
risque, pas un risque ? Est-ce que tu as
bossé sur ce sujet-là ? Oui, on a des
des chiffres très h euh variables selon
les sources vers lesquelles on se
tourne. Euh mais les migrations
environnementales à l'avenir vont être
extrêmement importantes. Euh on parle
beaucoup dans le public de
l'augmentation de la température moyenne
à la surface de la planète.
Euh
ces chiffres où on parle d'une
augmentation de 1,5 2°
ou 4° à la fin du siècle et cetera sont
très trompeurs. Pourquoi ? parce que les
augmentations de température seront
beaucoup plus importantes sur les
continents 2 tiers de la surface de la
planète, c'est les océans qui eux vont
se réchauffer beaucoup moins vite. Mais
donc dans l'Arctique et l'Antarctique,
dans les zones tropicales, on va voir
des augmentations de température de
l'ordre de 7 8° C. Et pour des
populations dans les zones tropicales
qui en plus ont une humidité de l'air
très importante de 85 90 %, il y a des
régions entières qui seront invivables
euh totalement invivables et l'on a des
projections qui euh euh estiment à euh
probablement euh euh euh 150
200 millions le nombre de gens qui vont
devoir
migrer de ces zones à brève échéance à
l'horizon 2030 et des chiffres encore
plus impressionnants pour
les années 2050 2060. Donc dans un pays
comme le Bangladesh où j'étais euh au
mois de mai, on a déjà sur une
population totale de ce pays de 26 de
165 millions, on a déjà environ euh 50
millions de personnes qui sont affectées
par les changements climatiques et qui
effectivement avec des des terres
salinisées, avec des des des champs qui
sont régulièrement inondés
[raclement de gorge] sont forcés de
migrer vers les villes. l'essentiel des
des bidonvillees de Daka, la capitale du
Bangladesh, ce sont des migrants
climatiques qui viennent de régions qui
sont exposés dans le le sud de
Bangladesh à proximité de de l'océan ou
bien dans le nord de Bangladesh parce
qu'on a des rivières qui sont
régulièrement sortent régulièrement de
leur lit à raison de de la fonte des
glaciers de l'Himalaya. Donc on a des
pays comme le Bangladesh extrêmement
vulnérables où les migrations
environnementales de masse ont déjà
commencé. L'Asie du Sud-Estulérable. Tu
disais le taux d'humidité plus les
températures, ça devient morbide,
mortifère, invivable.
Ça représente beaucoup de monde ça
aussi. Est-ce que tu penses que ça va
bien se passer, qu'on va tous se donner
la main et aider le monde à changer ou
est-ce que tu penses qu'on va se
permets-moi l'expression, se sur
la gueule, avoir un repli idéologique,
un repli identitaire, mettre des
barbelets à nos frontières parce que bah
les pays vont être déstabilisés, les
pays traversés vont être déstabilisés
parce que les gens vont pas accepter et
les gens vont défendre coûte que coûte
leur dernier petit bout de gras pendant
que des milliardaires à patatride vont
pouvoir s'expatrier dans des endroits où
il fait mieux vivre, moins chaud, où on
peut creuser des trous pour faire son
boomker en attendant que les pauvres se
dévorent.
Oui, ce scénario, ce scénario à la à la
Mad Max est est possible, il est
envisageable, il n'est pas exclure, il
n'est pas inévitable pour autant.
Mais il est clair que déjà aujourd'hui,
on assiste dans plusieurs pays à ce
cercle vicieux où les changements
climatiques, les les les ruptures
amenées par le changement climatique
amènent l'extrémisme et le terrorisme,
euh la chute des institutions et la
perte de contrôle des États sur les
territoires.
Et ces conflits à leur tour
amènent des des des migrations de
population et des désastres humanitaires
qui ne font que renforcer les impacts
des ruptures climatiques.
Toute la région du Sahel
subit aujourd'hui les impacts combinés
des changements climatiques et euh de la
de la radicalisation et du terrorisme.
Et ces phénomènes sont évidemment liés.
On risque d'avoir de plus en plus de
zones qui sont des zones où les
extrémismes viennent à proliférer parce
que les jeunes n'ont pas de perspective,
n'ont pas d'emploi qui leur sont
proposés, parce que les populations ont
dû migrer et n'ont pas d'alternative que
de se tourner vers la vers la violence.
Et c'est cela qui doit aujourd'hui nous
inquiéter. Donc c'est effectivement
d'ailleurs ce qui explique
l'augmentation du nombre de personnes
qui qui souffrent de la fin. Pendant des
années, on voyait ce chiffre
relativement décroître. On était à à 900
millions euh en 1990 et on était à à 790
millions en en 2015 et puis maintenant
les chiffres augmentent de nouveau à
raison de cette combinaison de choc
climatique et de conflits. Et c'est ça
vers quoi on va.
Tu parlais de du Malaoui. Tu as déjà été
au Mala ? J'ai été Mala oui.
Tu as été au Mala avec un tour opérateur
United Nation ou tu as été au Maladioui
Pac pack chaussures et à manger des
brochettes d'ora sur le bord des routes
? J'étais au Malais, je crois que
c'était en 2011 faire une mission sur la
question de la fin au Malaoui et j'ai
été effectivement
frappé du fait que l'on l'on l'on mange
des des rats au Malaï. C'est vrai, mais
ce qui m'a surtout frappé, c'est que
pour lutter contre la fin, le
gouvernement encourageait la production
de maïs donnant des semences et des et
des et des engrais au au paysans du
Malaoui. Et et donc on avait
une malnutrition très importante au
Malaoui parce que bien que le maïs on
est je dirais des une production
importante à l'hectare et ça permet de
de de produire des calories, c'est du
point de vue nutritif très insuffisant.
Et donc on a au Mala,
je dirais de ces recettes technologiques
euh euh relativement facile à mettre en
œuvre du point de vue logistique mais
qui ne répondent pas au problème de la
malnutrition. On avait, si vous voulez,
une politique euh permettant de réduire
la fin l'absence de calories
suffisantes, mais certainement pas de
réduire la malnutrition. Et souvent on
confond les deux phénomènes, mais on
peut avoir des populations mal nourries,
bien qu'elle dispose d'un d'un du d'un
nombre de calories suffisant par jour
pour survivre. Et c'est ce qu'on
problème aussi en Europe, les plus
Oui, absolument. Oui,
je t'ai coupé. Non, tu as fini. OK. Euh,
[raclement de gorge]
tu fais des cauchemars, c'est à à
ressasser, à voir, à te déplacer,
avoir des des camps de réfugié, les
enfants en des nutrition hyper
importantes, ouvert à toutes les
épidémies avec des des gens migration,
avec le la traite des humains, avec les
les bon, je t'en passer des meilleurs.
Est-ce que tu fais des cauchemars ?
Est-ce que psychologiquement tu es
atteint ? Est-ce que à l'ONU, il y a une
cellule psychologique pour les gens qui
vont, on va dire, fouiller un peu dans
les trèsfonds de notre société ?
Je je je ne suis pas fonctionnaire de
l'ONU et donc je ne bénéficierai pas de
ces services s'ils existaient, j'ignore
s'ils existent. Je mais mais ce qui est
évident, c'est que je suis confronté
régulièrement
à des chiffres, à des situations, à des
visages euh des vies euh qui
effectivement euh créent beaucoup
d'angoisses.
Euh j'essaie de ne pas transmettre cette
angoisse autour de moi.
J'ai des enfants que j'essaie de
protéger de ces nouvelles extrêmement
anxiogènes. Et je me fixe une règle,
c'est de ne jamais parler des problèmes
sans aussi évoquer des solutions. Parce
que si on parle des problèmes euh sans
parler des solutions, d'autres viendront
avec leurs propres solution et parfois
euh ces solutions me font aussi peur que
que les problèmes qu'il prétendent
résoudre. Euh je crois aussi que il faut
ne pas euphémiser les choses. Il faut
que je dirais le public se rende compte
euh de l'impasse dans lequel on est.
Mais le désespoir n'est pas
la bonne source de motivation pour
l'action. En fait, la désespérance que
l'on crée en évoquant l'imminence de
l'effondrement, par exemple, peut
conduire à des dépressions, à une
écoanxiété, les psychologues le document
très bien d'ailleurs,
à une à une démobilisation parce que
après tout, si le combat est perdu, à
quoi va à quoi sert-il de le conduire ce
combat ? Je vois des couples qui se
déchirent autour de cette question de
savoir ce qu'il faut faire par rapport
par exemple aux nouvelles qui viennent
du front du climat. Et donc je parle des
problèmes mais je parle aussi des
solutions qui me paraissent pouvoir être
recherchées pourvu que la volonté
politique puisse être créée et pourvu
qu'on qu'on arrive à se mobiliser pour
faire pression sur le gouvernement. Et
donc mon message c'est il faut agir. On
est on risque sinon de perdre la
bataille. il faut se battre et il sert à
quelque chose de se battre. Donc je ne
suis pas dans le désespoir, je ne suis
pas dans dans la dans dans l'attente de
l'effondrement, dans l'espoir que un
monde meilleur va surgir de de cet
effondrement de notre civilisation
thermoindustrielle.
Je suis dans le combat quotidien et
c'est pour moi aussi une thérapie. Ce
que les psychologues nous disent, c'est
que les personnes qui traversent le
mieux
la période actuelle euh avec tous les
messages anxiogènes que celle-ci
charient, ce sont les personnes qui se
mobilisent avec d'autres et qui se
battent parce que c'est une manière de
de ne pas tomber dans désespoir.
C'est quoi la chose la plus dure
psychologiquement parlant que tu été
amené à voir, avec laquelle tu es été le
plus exposé ? l'endroit du monde qui t'a
fait ouf
c'est c'est euh
deux expériences. J'étais en Malaisie où
je j'ai assisté à la coupe de forêts
primaire pour produire
nos notre huile de palme si vous voulez
dont nous dépendons parce que nous
importons via la Chine beaucoup d'huile
végétale d'Indonésie et de Malaisie.
Et j'ai eu un véritable choc quand j'ai
vu ces énormes tracteurs grands comme
des maisons qui coupait des forêts
devenu complètement lisse des énormes
espaces planes où l'on allait ensuite
planter des monocultures de palmah huile
des déserts verts. Je suis arrivé sur le
site, les gens on ont on ont voulu ont
arrêté les tracteurs et ont fuit pour
que je ne puisse pas les interpeller et
c'était une expérience tout à fait
terrible. J'avais une impression de de
fin du monde dans ce paysage devenu
lunaire où il y avait quelques jours
auparavant une une forêt une forêt
primaire. Ça c'est une expérience
extrêmement traumatisante. Et puis j'en
ai vécu une autre à Madagascar où j'ai
parlé avec une une famille euh qui en
fait vendait ses enfants parce qu'il
n'arriveraient pas à les nourrir.
Les vendait à qui ? à des familles plus
riches en ville qui allaient en faire
des espèces de semi-esclaves, des
travailleurs domestiques et et cette
famille me disait c'est la seule manière
pour nous de que nos enfants aient un
avenir, c'est de vendre ces enfants pour
qu'il pour qu'ils soient en fait au
service d'une famille riche dans la
capitale. C'est terrible être à ce point
dans la pauvreté qu'on en vienne à
vendre sa petite fille de 10 11 ans.
C'est terrible. Et ça c'est c'est la
réalité de la pauvreté dans ces pays.
Une autre chose genre quand tu as visité
un hôpital à Varansi
des des le sol en terre.
Moi je je reviens du Bangladesh et au
Bangladesh, j'étais quand même très
bouleversé par la situation des réfugiés
du Roya. Voilà un million de personnes.
Alors explique pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas ce qui se passe au
presque 1 million de personnes qui ont
migré de Birmanie de Myanmar en 2017.
parce que exposé à des actes de génocide
euh au Myanmar et ce sont des personnes
qui sont dans des camps à la frontière
entre le Bangladesh et le Myanmar mais
sur le territoire du Bangladesh et qui
[grognement] habitent dans 33 camps qui
sont aujourd'hui entourés de barbelet
depuis 2019 et ce sont des gens qui
n'ont pour seul soutien que le soutien
humanitaire des agences des Nations
Unies et des ONG. Donc, ce sont des gens
qui ne n'ont pas le droit de travailler,
n'ont pas d'activité productive. Donc,
il y a une une oisiveté de tous les
instants dans ces camps-là. Les gens
n'ont rien à faire, littéralement. Et ce
sont des personnes qui n'ont aucune
perspective et qui en plus ne peuvent
pas construire en dur parce qu'on ne
veut pas qu'elles reste là à long terme.
Et donc elles ne peuvent que s'abriter
dans des hutes de tôle dans un contexte
où il fait extrêmement chaud et humide.
J'ai passé là quelques jours mais mais
c'est invivable et je n'ose pas imaginer
euh des personnes qui passent là tout le
temps qu' qu'elles ont. Donc, ce sont
des populations
sans aucune perspective qui ne peuvent
pas retourner au Myanmar parce que les
conditions ne sont pas du tout propice à
leur retour et que le Bangladesh
n'autorise pas à véritablement se mêler
à la population pour pour développer des
activités et travailler. Et donc voilà,
1 million de personnes en désespoir
complet. Euh en plus, les agences des
Nations-Unis n'obtiennent pas des
gouvernements euh le financement
nécessaire à aider ces population comme
il le faudrait. Les rations alimentaires
ont été coupées en juin de nouveau euh
enfin en en mai puis de nouveau en juin.
Aujourd'hui, euh ces rations
alimentaires sont tout à fait
insuffisantes pour protéger les enfants
de la sous-alimentation et voilà la
situation à laquelle j'ai j'ai assisté.
et donc parler avec ses réfugiés,
constater que euh la mortalité infantile
progresse et que les enfants sont en en
sont sont sont sous-alimentés,
donc avec un développement cérébral euh
ral
entravé. Effectivement, c'est c'est tout
à fait dramatique. Donc voilà et c'est
c'est cela aussi dans ces pays-là.
Tu parles des roingas, mais les roingas
ça fait bien 40 ans qu'ils sont
persécutés à gauche et à droite. Non, il
y a pas du pétrole là où ils habitent
juste en dessous de leurs pieds où il y
a pas des ressources énergétiques ?
Alors, les RIA sont surtout présents
dans un province du Myanmar qui
s'appelle l'état de Rakin où ils sont
persécutés pour des raisons à la fois
ethniques et et religieuses. Ce ne sont
pas des des bouddhistes, ce sont des des
musulmans. Et euh c'est une région qui
effectivement a des des gisements
pétroliers et gaziers.
[grognement]
Mais les roingas n'ont jamais bénéficié
de cela et ce sont des petits pêcheurs,
des agriculteurs et et ils vivrent d'une
voilà d'une agriculture de pêche de
subsistence.
Euh la crise énergétique à l'ONU, euh
ils en parlent, ils en parlent pas. La
la déplession des des ressources
énergétiques, ils en parlent, ils en
parlent pas. Ils font des des plans sur
la comète, ils font des scénarios, ils
font de l'anticipation. Est-ce que la
rarifaction du pétrole ça les inquiète ?
Cela inquiète évidemment tout le monde.
Je crois que l'urgence aujourd'hui c'est
de passer à autre chose.
Mais on est dans un dans un système où
les économistes
de moins en moins, mais encore toujours
continuent
de de nier que la rareté est un est un
est un vrai est un vrai problème. Je
m'explique.
Lorsque les prix augmentent,
on entend encore beaucoup de voix pour
dire cela va inciter à développer des
technologies permettant de de de
surmonter ce problème de la rareté et de
faire de nouveau baisser les prix. Et
l'on continue à parler à parier chaque
fois sur les innovations technologiques,
sur les sursauts technologiques dont
nous serions capables pour répondre à ce
problème de la rareté. Je suis très
frappé d'ailleurs de voir que quand on a
euh on a célébré récemment le 50e
anniversaire de la publication du
rapport du club de Rome les limites de
la croissance publié donc en en 1972 et
qui nous alertait sur la rarfaction des
ressources. Et ce rapport a été
accueilli en 1972 par les sarcasmes des
économistes qui disaient "On parle
réflexion des ressources mais vous savez
dès lors que les prix vont monter ça va
stimuler les entreprises à développer
des nouvelles techniques de forage
d'exploitation et et et des techniques
de production qui vont permettre de
réduire l'usage et ressources. Donc
cette rareté est un fantasme et en fait
on ne va jamais affronter le mur de la
rareté. Mais soyons très clair, si l'on
exploite toutes les ressources de
pétrole, de gaz, évidemment de charbon
dont on dispose aujourd'hui et qui sont
déjà documentés, la planète va exploser.
Donc on ne peut pas
on ne peut pas accepter que les
entreprises aujourd'hui qui ont des
droits d'exploitation sur des gisements
gaziers ou pétroliers continuent
d'exploiter jusqu'au bout ces gisements.
Ce n'est tout simplement pas viable, pas
acceptable. Et donc pour sortir de cela
et bien il faut euh je le crois aller
vers la nationalisation de ces
entreprises pétrolière et et et gazière
euh parce que euh sinon ces entreprises
vont continuer de se sentir tenues de
donner des des retours aux actionnaires
et d'exploiter jusqu'au bout les
gisements dont elles elles ont dont
elles sont propriétaires. Aujourd'hui,
la valeur d'une action de Total Ennergie
par exemple repose repose notamment sur
le fait que Total Energie a des droits
d'exploitation sur un très grand nombre
de de gisements gaziers et pétroliers
qui n pas du diable. Ils ont un
savoir-faire, ils savent forer des
trous, ça repose pas que sur ça.
Oui, mais on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
continuer d'accepter que des entreprises
euh euh menacent la viabilité même de la
planète pour
l'espèce humaine au nom de la
rentabilité d'un investissement qu'elles
ont fait. Donc, il faut trouver des
solutions et et
ne nous arrêtons de croire que les
ingénieurs ont on ont réponse à tout. On
est dans une dans un technoisme qui me
sidère complètement
parce que c'est la réponse qu'on nous
donne souvent, c'est que on va aller
vers des technologies plus propres, plus
vertes, on va pouvoir développer une
croissance verte et donc c'est là que
réside la solution. Malheureusement, ce
n'est pas le cas.
Donc, on arrête la croissance.
Euh oui, il faut arrêter de rechercher
la croissance à tout prix. Il faut une
économie, je l'ai dit tout à l'heure,
stationnaire tout en permettant aux pays
pauvres de se développer pour répondre
aux besoins essentiels de leur
population. Donc, il faut un il faut
aller vers un scénario de de contraction
convergence si vous voulez.
L'intrication des du système financier
basé depuis 40 ans sur une fonction
exponentielle de croissance.
Euh tu penses pas que si on arrête la
croissance ou qu'on la diminué un petit
peu, cet immense château de cartes très
rassurant depuis les 50 dernières
années, s'il s'effondre,
ça fera peut-être un énorme trouble
à euh un réchauffement climatique
débridé.
C'est un problème hyper complexe parce
qu'on a des états et des ménages très
endettés et la croissance est une sorte
de drogue. Il faut parler d'une
assuitude à la croissance de nos
économies dont il est très difficile de
se débarrasser et le sevrage immédiat
est un problème. Donc il faut trouver
d'autres solutions. avec mon équipe,
nous travaillons à des scénarios
pour les années qui viennent et c'est le
chantier, l'objectif que je me fixe.
Comment peut-on maintenir l'État
providence ? Comment peut-on continuer à
financer les politiques sociales, les
services publics sans croissance ? On
peut le faire. il faut financer
autrement que euh en continuant de de de
rechercher des gains de productivité
dans le travail et en continuant de de
de de
maximiser l'efficience de de la
production et il faut d'autres manières
de financer euh si vous voulez les
politiques sociales notamment par une
fiscalité plus progressive en en taxant
non seulement le le le travail et
d'ailleurs en taxant beaucoup moins mais
en en en taxant les les fortunes, le
patrimoine, en taxant euh l'exploitation
d'énergie fossile et les transactions
financières. Donc on a on doit inventer
d'autres manières de financer l'état
providence qui ne passent pas
nécessairement par la case croissance.
C'est cela qu'il faut faire pour
atterrir en douceur, ralentir en
douceur. On ne peut pas continuer dans
le schéma actuel.
Olivier, est-ce que tu as trois bouquins
à conseiller à ma communauté ?
Écoutez, on parle beaucoup de de ces
questions de de croissance, de
post-croissance, d'alternative et et un
livre que je voudrais recommander qui me
paraît extrêmement lucide et bien
documenté sur la question, c'est le
livre de de Timothé Paralir
ou périr qui est je crois une excellente
synthèse de la question.
Je
m'en voudrais aussi de ne pas
recommander un livre d'un italien qui
s'appelle Stefano Bonnie
et qui s'appelle Homo confort
qui montre combien la recherche du
confort dans nos existences est une
véritable entrave à la recherche d'une
de solution pour une société plus
durable et je crois qu'il touche quelque
chose d'extrêmement important dans notre
civilisation et puis je le cite en 3è
lieu, mais mais il mérite à mes yeux la
la médaille d'or. C'est un un philosophe
et sociologue allemand qui s'appelle
Hartmut Rosa et qui a travaillé sur les
notions d'accélération et de résonance.
accélération, résonance. Ce sont les
titres de ces deux ouvrages majeurs. Il
a aussi publié des ouvrages beaucoup
plus accessibles et courts. Et ce que
nous montre Artmout Rosa, c'est que nous
sommes dans une société qui est victime
d'une véritable
maladie qui réside dans la recherche
permanente de l'accélération et que nous
perdons notre capacité à nous rapporter
les uns aux autres avec cette résonance
qu'on peut traduire par empathie.
attention à l'autre, capacité d'être
surpris et émerveillé par l'autre. Si
vous voulez, ce qu'il nous montre à
juste titre, je crois, c'est que peu à
peu, nous nous rapportons les uns aux
autres parce que nous cherchons à nous
utiliser les uns les autres. les autres
deviennent des moyens au service de mes
objectifs. Le monde est une ressource à
exploiter. La nature euh est euh un une
poubelle dans laquelle on déverse nos
déchets ou euh un un espace où nous
pouvons puiser les ressources
nécessaires, satisfaire nos besoins.
Bref, nous avons des rapports
d'instrumentalisation
à ce qui nous entourent et il faut aller
de ces rapports d'instrumentalisation à
des rapports de résonance, d'attention,
d'empathie. Et c'est cela, je crois que
que que Artm Rosa nous montre et c'est
un message absolument important à
entendre aujourd'hui.
Harmonique et sérentipité.
Belle manière de résumer mon propos. Euh
quand tu étais jeune, trois bouquins qui
ont compté pour toi.
Ma prise de conscience des enjeux que je
travaille aujourd'hui, elle est venue de
ma lecture des travaux de René Dumont.
René Dumont, agronome français,
premier candidat écologiste à l'élection
présidentielle en en 1974,
écrivait dans ces années-là mais il y a
50 ans,
des livres qui demeurent d'une actualité
parfaite aujourd'hui.
Et on peut dire que des auteurs comme
Ivanilic
ou André Gorz, fondateur de l'économie
politique, était bien plus visionnaire
que les écologistes ne le sont
aujourd'hui. Et donc Dumont, Il Gz sont
des auteurs qui m'ont beaucoup marqué,
qui m'ont formé et je trouve
étonnant que leur message demeure d'une
d'une telle actualité aujourd'hui.
Est-ce que tu as un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? une bouteille à la
mer, quelque chose d'impérissable qui
restera sur les réseaux sociaux, sur
l'internet, sur notre intelligence
horizontale et collective. Mais moi, je
crois qu'il faut multiplier les manières
de de de résister au à la à la à la
machine broyeuse de de de la société de
consommation qui qui est en train de
nous de nous épuiser. Et et parmi les
manières de résister, il y a ce que ce
que j'appellerais le
la désobéissance civile par la sortie de
la société de consommation. Euh je
m'explique euh si les petits écogestes
que l'on pose au quotidien,
c'est quoi les petits écogestes du
quotidien faire caca dans la su plus ne
plus prendre l'avion, euh arrêter de
manger de la viande, euh euh aller vers
des les circuits courts en matière
alimentaire et et et s'approvisionner
autrement qu'à qu'à travers les plats
préparés dans les supermarchés et
cetera. Il y a plein de gestes que les
gens font, mais ces gestes sont
individuels, ils ne sont pas
collectivisés et ils ne sont pas
politisés. C'est-à-dire que on n'envoie
pas un message au politique disant "Les
gestes que je pose, je voudrais bien que
vous les souteniez pour qu'il soit
abordable,
c'est-à-dire économiquement accessible
et pour qu'il soit facile à poser." Et
donc moi, je rêve que l'on se mette
ensemble pour que ces écogestes soient
politisés et collectivisés pour que
ensemble l'on décide par exemple de
boycotter telle firme, de prendre
l'engagement de ne pas prendre l'avion
pendant cet été-là.
C'est pas interdit le boycotte.
Ah non, pas que je sache et que et que
ces échogestes qui sont une manière pour
chacun de se donner bonne conscience et
de s'imaginer faire partie de la
solution pour qu'on puisse en faire une
arme politique. Et ce n'est pas la
désufficience civile au sens où l'on
viole des règles, mais c'est une sortie
de la société de consommation, de
l'injonction permanente à consommer qui
nous est faite. Je crois que ça peut
être très subversif et surtout c'est une
manière de sortir de cette espèce de de
jeu de ping-pong où les politiques
disent les gens ne sont pas prêts au
changement, ils veulent leur confort, on
ne va pas leur imposer des sacrifices et
et où les gens disent eux on est prêt à
changer mais il faut que les politiques
nous y aident. Par exemple, il faut des
trains de nuit, il faut investir
transport en commun, il faut nous donner
des indications sur la provenance de de
nos aliments, il faut que l'agricult que
les aliments issus de l'agriculture bio
ou paysane soient beaucoup plus
abordable. Bref, les gens sont prêts à
changer, mais il faut que les politiques
accompagnent, aident ces changements. Et
pour sortir de ce jeu de ping-pong, euh
de cette espèce de de de circularité
épuisante, euh il faut euh désobéir à
l'injonction de consommer et c'est cela
mon appel.
Olivier de Scuter, merci.
Avec grand plaisir.
[musique]